Hey there, Will Arnett here from SmartList. It's the podcast where Jason Bateman, Sean Hayes, and I interview somebody. Two of us don't know who that person is because one of us has brought on a surprise guest. That's the whole conceit. I wish I could describe it better, but I'm not that smart. So it's SmartList and it's starting now. You never did a guest spot over on the Morgan Middy, huh? No, but I would have.
大家好，我是《SmartLess》的威尔·阿奈特。这是一档我和杰森·贝特曼、肖恩·海耶斯一起采访嘉宾的播客。我们俩通常不知道嘉宾是谁，因为其中一人会带来一个神秘嘉宾。这就是全部的套路。我真希望自己能把它描述得更好，但我没那么聪明。所以这就是《SmartLess》，现在开始。你以前从来没去摩根米迪客串过，对吧？没有，不过我本来愿意的。
What was your best guest spot when you were a kid? Night Rider. Yeah, of course. Night Rider just made my year. I was 15, and so I couldn't drive yet. So this was an opportunity not only to guest on the best show in the world, but also drive a Trans-Am owned by The Hoff and see how they do all the tricks over there. They had like a little guy sitting behind the seat that was like looking through this
你小时候最棒的客串经历是什么？《霹雳游侠》。对，当然。《霹雳游侠》简直让我度过了绝赞的一年。我当时15岁，还不会开车。所以这不仅是一个在全世界最好的节目中客串的机会，还能开一辆由“霍夫”本人拥有的超智跑车，看看他们是怎么在那里制作各种特效的。他们有个小伙子坐在座椅后面，透过座椅上的某种
mesh sort of headpiece in the seat. I loved all the movie magic. I was going to say, you would have made a good computer if they already had. You would have been a good, I would have cast you as a computer, I'd still cast you as a computer. Wait, because, because I know that about you. It was on the other day, not your episode, but Night Rider and Scotty and I turned it on and they did this like super fancy interior shot of the car.
网状头枕往外看。我喜欢所有的电影魔法。我本来想说，如果你早点出生，你肯定能当个好电脑。你会当个不错的……我本来会把你选为电脑，我现在依然会把你选为电脑。等等，因为……因为我了解你。前几天电视在播，不是你的那一集，而是《霹雳游侠》，斯科特和我把它打开了，他们拍了一个汽车内部的超酷炫特写镜头。
And I'm telling you right now, it was disgusting in there. It was like, there was like dust and like wrappers all around it and like all the scratches on it. Like it was not pristine at all. Wow. The onset dresser was not great on the job. 35 years later, you're taking shots at, you know, Transpo and picture cars. Great.
我向你保证，里面恶心极了。到处都是灰尘和包装纸，上面还有各种划痕。一点也不崭新。哇。当年的布景师工作真不咋地。35岁之后，你居然开始吐槽交通部门和道具车了。太棒了。
We'll have the local on your ass by Monday. Hey guys, I'm so glad that we're here today because we have a guest on our show and we say this a lot, you know, deserves no introduction, but this is just another example of that. This is a person who has won almost every award it's possible to win in, well, you know what? I'll let him tell you about it. Ladies and gentlemen, Mr. Ricky Gervais. Oh.
周一前我们就会让当地工会找你麻烦。嘿，伙计们，我很高兴我们今天能聚在这里，因为我们节目今天来了一位嘉宾——我们经常这么说——你知道的，他根本不需要介绍，但这又是另一个完美的例子。这是一位几乎赢得了所有可能获得的奖项的人，嗯，你知道吗？我让他自己告诉你吧。女士们先生们，瑞奇·热维斯先生。噢。
Oh. Oh, it's a nice shot of the awards in the back. Look at all the awards. Guys, it's not all of them. It's half of them. There's lots of walls. Wow. I nearly laughed a couple of times when I was waiting with you talking about it.
噢。噢，后面那个奖杯的特写真不错。看看所有的奖项。伙计们，这还不是全部。这只是那一半。有好多墙呢。哇。刚才跟你聊天等候的时候，我差点笑出来了。
Wait, what did you win the guitar for? I didn't win that, did I? That's just something for the ladies. When they're looking at your awards, let me play a little tune for you. Oh, my word. Look at you. What a joy. This is.
等等，你拿吉他赢了什么奖？我没拿那个奖吧？那只是为了吸引女士们的眼球。当她们看着你的奖项时，让我为你弹一曲吧。天哪。看看你。太令人高兴了。这真是。
Yeah. It's so nice to meet you. I've never met you. I'm a huge, huge, huge fan. Thank you. How's it going, man? Good, man. You guys don't know each other?
对。很高兴认识你。我从来没见过你。我是你超级、超级、超级的粉丝。谢谢。最近怎么样，老兄？很好，老兄。你们俩以前不认识吗？
No. No. You know, there's one time I saw you standing outside of the Beverly Hills Hotel, and there was nobody else. And I was like, oh my God, that's Ricky. I am a huge fan. Should I say something? And then I fast forward in my head if I just go, hey, hey, Ricky, I'm Sean.
不。不。你知道吗，有一次我看到你站在比佛利山庄酒店外面，周围没有别人。当时我就想：哦天哪，那是瑞奇。我是他的超级粉丝。我是不是该说点什么？然后在脑海里快进，如果我走过去说：嘿，嘿，瑞奇，我是肖恩。
And if I didn't know if you know who I was, and then you'd be like, hey, and then it would just end. And so I was like, maybe I should skip that. It's kind of how it's going now. It's kind of what's happening. Well, you know, one time I was at Christmas party at Meg Ryan's house. This is decades ago. And Steven Spielberg was in there and I'm talking and I've never met him.
如果我不知道你知不知道我是谁，然后你就会说：嘿，接着对话就直接结束了。所以我当时想：也许我该跳过这一步。这就有点像我们现在这样。这就是正在发生的事情。好吧，你知道的，有一次我在梅格·瑞恩家的圣诞派对上。那是几十年前的事了。史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格也在那儿，我在说话，而且我从没见过他。
And he's like, oh my God. And I couldn't believe he knew who I was. We're talking and talking and talking for like two hours. It was awesome. And then I made this huge goodbye. I was like, bye, Steven. Nice to meet you. I go out to the valet in front of the house and nobody's there, right?
然后他说：噢，天哪。我简直不敢相信他知道我是谁。我们聊啊聊啊聊了大约两个小时。太棒了。然后我郑重其事地告别了。我说：再见，史蒂芬。很高兴认识你。我走到房子前面的代客泊车处，一个人也没有，对吧？
And I'm waiting for my car, waiting for my car. And then Steven Spielberg walks up and it's just us two. And we already had a massive goodbye. So then I was like, hey, how are you? And it was just awful. It would have been better if he had just said, hi, how are you? I'm Steven. In that moment.
我在等我的车，等我的车。然后史蒂芬·斯皮尔伯格走了过来，只剩下我们两个。我们之前已经正式道过别了。所以我当时就说：嘿，你好吗？这简直糟透了。如果他当时只是说：嗨，你好吗？我是史蒂芬。那会好得多。
Or if he just said, bye, Benjamin. Bye, Benjamin. Ricky, do you remember a few years ago you were walking across the street here in LA and I saw you and Jane walking across and I pulled up and I rolled my window down and I said, hey, can I get a picture? And you were at first you're like, oh, fuck, how are you doing? And then he realized. And you went, don't give me the fucking wave.
或者如果他只是说：再见，本杰明。再见，本杰明。瑞奇，你还记得几年前你和简在洛杉矶这里过马路吗？我看到你们俩在过马路，于是我把车开过去，摇下车窗说：嘿，我能拍张照片吗？你一开始的反应是：噢，操，你干嘛呢？然后你认出来了。接着你说道：别冲我他妈的挥手。
It's Will. And you actually got out. We're going to let the guest talk here in a second. But how many times have you guys been in the car and you like honk at somebody and then you pull up alongside him and you know that person? Oh yeah. Oh, you mean angrily honk? Yeah.
我是威尔。你甚至还下了车。我们一会儿再让嘉宾说话。但你们在车里时，按别人喇叭然后把车开到旁边发现那人你认识，这种情况发生过多少次？哦，是的。哦，你是说生气地按喇叭？对。
Sorry. Like just anything. If an English person honks, it's like in a front, it's like people get out, what the fuck. But in America, it's just like honk for anything. Right. Yeah. It's like you've really devalued the honk.
抱歉。就像随便什么情况。如果一个英国人按喇叭，那就好像是一种冒犯，人们会出来骂“他妈的干嘛”。但在美国，无论什么事都能按喇叭。对。没错。就好像你们把按喇叭的意义彻底贬低了。
Especially in New York. You've devalued the honk. Yeah. I think you're right. We should take it back. I think that you're right. Take it right back. So a honk is like, it's like the finger or something.
尤其是在纽约。你们把按喇叭贬得一文不值。对。我觉得你说得对。我们应该把它收回。我觉得你说得对。彻底收回来。所以按喇叭就像是，就像竖中指什么的。
What the fuck are you doing? We should take him out of the car. Hold on. Hold on. What about time differences? I'm in LA, so I'm drinking coffee. Was that ale? I just saw.
你他妈在干什么？我们应该把他拉下车。等等。等等。有时差吗？我在洛杉矶，所以我正在喝咖啡。那是艾尔啤酒吗？我刚刚看见的。
Ale. Is that what you people call it? Yes. Forsooth. It was a mead, Sire. Look at that. God, that looks good. It's a beer.
艾尔啤酒。这就是你们这群人对它的称呼？是的。千真万确。这是蜂蜜酒，长官。瞧瞧那个。天哪，看起来真不错。这就是啤酒。
As opposed to a lager. Well, it's an IPA, an Indian Pale Ale, yes. And what is that, by the way? That came in after I stopped. So what is IPA? Oh, am I the only drinker here now? Well, Sean. I don't know.
相对于拉格啤酒而言。好吧，这是IPA，即印度淡色艾尔，是的。顺便问一下，那是什么？那是我戒酒之后才出现的。所以什么是IPA？哦，难道现在这里只有我一个人在喝酒吗？嗯，肖恩。我不知道。
Sean is a big drinker. I saw him last night. Yeah. Good. What is it? So the Indian Pale Ale. Do you know what that is? Yeah.
肖恩是个大酒鬼。我昨晚还看见他了。对。很好。那是什么？所以印度淡色艾尔。你知道那是什么吗？对。
I can't be more specific. I mean, there's a three-word description, and I don't know of any other drink that's got three words already to really specify what it is. Oh, what? Yeah. Oh. I'm in. But wait a second, though.
我没法更具体地解释了。我的意思是，这是一个三个词的描述，而且我不知道还有什么其他饮品已经用三个词来精确定义它了。哦，什么？对。噢。我明白了。但等一下。
But wait a second. Indians were not known for making beer when I was last drinking beer, so where did that come from? Sorry. Are you saying Indian in the real term, the subcontinent of India in Asia, or what you call Indians, which are Native Americans, just what you arrogantly called Indians? Yeah. I just want to say, Ricky, just give Jason enough rope.
但等一下。在我最后一次喝酒的时候，印度人并不是以酿造啤酒而闻名，所以这到底是从哪来的？抱歉。你是说真正意义上的印度人，也就是亚洲的印度次大陆，还是你们所谓的“印第安人”，也就是美洲原住民——你们傲慢地称他们为印度人的那种？对。我只想说，瑞奇，给杰森足够的绳子就行了。
He's about to hang himself. Go ahead, Jason. About to hang my career. Oh, leave some slack on it. But I'm assuming the Indian of Indian Pale Ale means people from India, yes? Yes. I think so. I think it was probably something equally racist in that sort of British colonial history.
他快要自取灭亡了。说吧，杰森。快要毁了我的职业生涯了。哦，给他留点余地吧。不过我假设“印度淡色艾尔”里的“印度”是指印度人，对吧？是的。我想是吧。这大概是英国殖民历史中同样带有种族色彩的东西吧。
Yeah. So he said, we're having that. We're having that. This is Indian Pale Ale. It's ours now. It's ours now. Honestly, we've gone into rounds beyond my knowledge of what I'm drinking. All I know is it's 5% alcohol.
对。所以他说：我们要这个。我们要这个。这就是印度淡色艾尔。现在归我们了。现在归我们了。说实话，我们讨论的范围已经超出了我对所喝饮品的认知。我只知道它有5%的酒精度。
It's 6 PM. That's all I need to know. And do you have it? Is this a daily thing about this time that you have an Indian Pale Ale? Yes, it is. Are you only good for about 20 minutes? Is this an intervention? Yeah, this is intervention, the podcast.
现在是下午6点。这就是我需要知道的全部。你经常这样吗？差不多每天这个时候你都会来一杯印度淡色艾尔？是的，确实如此。你清醒的时间大概只有20分钟吗？这是在搞干预戒酒吗？对，这是干预戒酒播客。
I don't know if you knew about that. Come on in, Jane. Jane, come on in. I'm going to jack up in a minute. Is that all right? Oh, that's fine. It's just drinking. We don't mind.
我不知道你知不知道这事。进来吧，简。简，快进来。我一会儿就要去打针了。行吗？哦，没关系。只是喝点酒而已。我们不介意。
Exactly, yeah. So did you just, you know, you're rewarding yourself because you've just probably, probably just popped out of the gym. You probably in and out. I have. Yeah, have you? Would you? Oh, of course you have.
没错，是的。所以你刚才，你知道的，你这是在犒劳自己，因为你可能、可能刚从健身房出来。你可能刚去过。我是去过。是的，你去过吗？你会吗？哦，你当然去过了。
Look at that. Showing us his guns. And that's all natural. People say to me, hey, you're on the juice. I go, fuck you. Fuck you. But that's why they think you're rages. Rages.
看看那个。向我们展示他的肌肉。而且那全是纯天然的。人们对我说：嘿，你打了激素吧。我说：操你的。操你的。但这就是为什么他们觉得你很暴躁。暴躁。
You know, you do have a build, Rick. You always have, was there a time in your life when you, when you were a gym rat and you just love to just blast buys and back? No. Blast. Listen. Blast. You must have, because that's that you're not born with, with pipes like that.
你知道的，你确实很有型，瑞奇。你一直都……你生命中有没有那么一段时间，当你是个健身迷，就喜欢疯狂锻炼二头肌和背部？没有。疯狂。听着。疯狂。你肯定有过，因为那样的手臂不是天生就能有的。
Are you? No. No. It's just a shame this is only audio because they can't see me. They can imagine. I'm posing at the moment and I've got to tell my fake town is dripping off me. With a guitar and an IPA. Exactly.
对吧？没有。没有。真可惜这只是音频，因为他们看不到我。他们可以想象。我刚才在摆造型，我得说我的假黑油正从我身上往下流呢。拿着一把吉他和一杯IPA。没错。
Yeah. I do. I do. I work out every day. I try to. It's getting harder and harder. But my, and I probably shouldn't be because everything is absolutely fucked on me now. I've got two sprained ankles, which I, which is terrible.
对。我确实。我确实。我每天都锻炼。我尽量。这变得越来越难了。但我的……我可能不该这样，因为现在我浑身都彻底废了。我有两次脚踝扭伤，这太糟糕了。
I still run on. No, terrible knees. I can't bend without them. I'm cricking. I've got a bad back. My shoulders are fucked. I've got tennis elbow. Yeah.
我还在跑步。不，膝盖太糟了。我连弯曲都不行，会咔咔作响。我背疼。肩膀废了。我有网球肘。对。
I'm absolutely, but I refuse to stop doing anything. Mostly from street fighting. Is that right? Because I. Yeah. I'm like, yeah. Yeah. Hand to hand.
我整个人都……但我拒绝停止做任何事。主要来自街头斗殴。是吗？因为我。对。我喜欢。对。肉搏战。
Yeah. I'm punch drunk. Yeah. But how old are you? 59. Yeah. I'm about to be 52 and everything hurts a little bit. Fuck off.
对。我被打得神魂颠倒。对。但你多大了？59岁。对。我快52岁了，浑身都有点疼。滚开。
You're older than me. No. How dare you? This hair is real. Look at this. I've had no work. I don't have two body waxes a day. Wait a second.
你比我还大。没有。你怎么敢？这头发是真的。瞧瞧这个。我没做过任何医美。我一天不拔两次体毛。等一下。
I'm on swim team. I can't have any hair on my body. You're only, he's only 52. Is he telling the truth? Well, I won't be 52 till January. Christ. He won't turn to the side because then you'll see the scotch tape and all the rubber bands and stuff.
我是游泳队的。我身上不能有一根毛。他才52岁。他说的是实话吗？好吧，我到一月份才满52岁。天哪。他不敢转过身去，因为那样你就会看到透明胶带、所有橡皮筋之类奇奇怪怪的东西了。
But he looks amazing from the front. Ricky, do you have a place in LA? Or do you only live in New York? I've got a place in New York. I've had it for a while actually. But I've had a special this year. I've spent most of my time in Leafy Hampstead. Will's been here.
但他从正面看起来太棒了。瑞奇，你在洛杉矶有房产吗？还是说你只住在纽约？我在纽约有房产。其实我买了好一阵子了。但我今年有个特殊情况。我大部分时间都在绿树成荫的汉普斯特德度过。威尔去过那里。
It's beautiful. It's a great spot and you live next to the vicar. I do. Yeah. Who's that? Yeah, who is that? It's just a vicar. He said the vicar.
那很美。那是个好地方，而且你住在牧师住宅旁边。我确实住在那。对。那是谁？对，那是谁？就是一个牧师。他说的是牧师。
But it's a vicar. There's thousands. I live next to one of them. What's a vicar? A vicar? Yeah. You don't know what a vicar is. Uh-oh.
但这只是个牧师。有成千上万个呢。我就住在其中一个旁边。什么是牧师？牧师？对。你不知道什么是牧师。噢哦。
Allow Ricky to relieve you of your ignorance. Go ahead, Ricky. A vicar? It's a deep list. Like a preacher. Like a preacher. Like a local priest. Yeah.
让瑞奇来拯救你的无知吧。说吧，瑞奇。牧师？这可长见识了。就像一个布道者。就像一个布道者。就像当地的神父。对。
So you live next to a priest? A vicar, yeah. It's true. You live next to a priest's house? Listen, this podcast is, I mean, it's like I'm teaching you like English. And then I have to explain it. I mean, we spent three minutes on what's Indian paleo. It's not that important.
所以你住在一个神父旁边？牧师，对。真的。你住在神父的房子旁边？听着，这个播客，我的意思就好像我在教你英语。然后我还得解释。我的意思是，我们在“什么是印度淡色艾尔”上面花了三分钟。这没那么重要。
What's a vicar? Fucking hell. Click. Well, listen, you've spent time with Bateman before for Christ's sake. You know what you're getting into. I have. I couldn't believe my luck. I was a huge fan of Teen Wolf.
什么是牧师？他妈的。见鬼。好吧，听着看在上帝的份上，你以前也和贝特曼待过一段时间。你知道你要面对的是什么。我有过。我简直不敢相信自己的运气。我是《十八岁之狼》的超级粉丝。
Sure. Two. Two? Oh, I haven't seen two. No. Oh. Can I. So, so can I tell you.
当然。第二部？第二部？哦，我没看过第二部。不。哦。我可以。所以……所以能让我说吗？
So the first time Ricky that I became aware of you was from watching the office. And Janine Garofalo had video tapes at the time of the office and she brought them back and she gave them to Amy and me and we watched them. We were about to start a rest of development and Jason and I started watching both obsessively and we were just absolutely obsessed with the office. And we just thought we'd never seen anything like it. It was just brilliant. And I remember about you were coming to, you would come to LA for maybe the Golden Globes
所以瑞奇，我第一次知道你，是从看《办公室》开始的。当时珍妮·加罗法洛手里有《办公室》的录像带，她带了回来，交给了我和艾米，我们看了。我们当时正准备拍《发展受阻》，我和杰森开始疯狂地追看，我们对《办公室》简直痴迷得不行。我们当时觉得从没看过这样的作品。简直太精彩了。我还记得你当时要来……你可能会因为金球奖之类的事情来到洛杉矶。
or something in, in, we met briefly and we exchanged numbers and you were going to come to the set of a rest of development. You remember. And I remember saying to the set PA, I said, can I get a drive on at the lot? And she said, yeah, give me the name. And I said, Ricky Gervais and you weren't yet a household name in this country. Still not. And she said, well, and she said, what is it?
或者别的什么，我们在那儿简短地碰了面，交换了电话号码，你本打算去《发展受阻》的片场。你还记得吗。我记得当时对片场制片助理说：我能拿到一张停车场通行证吗？她说：行，告诉我名字。我说：瑞奇·热维斯——当时你在国内还不是家喻户晓的名字。现在也不是。她说：嗯。然后她问：叫什么？
I said, Ricky Gervais. And she said, can you spell it for me? And I actually stopped her and I said, I want you to remember this moment because you're going to be really embarrassed when you look back at it. And she was like, okay, whatever. And you came and that was our first experience. And we were just, Jason, do you remember how blown away we were back? We couldn't get enough of that show.
我说：瑞奇·热维斯。她说：你能为我拼写一下吗？我当场拦住她并说道：我希望你记住这个时刻，因为等你回想起来时会觉得非常尴尬。她当时反应是：好吧，随便吧。然后你来了，那是我们的第一次经历。我们简直……杰森，你还记得当时我们有多震撼吗？我们对那部剧简直爱不释手。
And I still, it's uncomfortable for me to even talk to Ricky. I'm a little starstruck. I ended up getting enough of it. I ended up getting enough of it. That was at the very beginning of the show. That and Jeffrey Tambor shaped, at least for me, the whole comedic tone of Arrested Development. 100%.
直到现在，跟瑞奇说话对我来说都觉得不太自在。我有点追星的心态。我最后彻底爱上了它。我最后对它爱不释手。那是在剧集刚开始的时候。那部剧和杰弗瑞·塔伯的塑造，至少对我来说，奠定了《发展受阻》整部剧的喜剧基调。百分之百。
I kind of knew that there was that kind of funny, but I'd never seen it executed so consistently. And that was just sort of my North Star, what I was trying to point towards. It was a weird way to say this, but it was liberating to watch you in that show. It really was. It opened up a whole other, for me anyway, it felt like it opened up a whole other way, like, okay, this, this is a possibility to go. If he's not acting well, we can all get away with it.
我以前多少知道有那种搞笑风格，但从没见过它执行得如此连贯。那就像是我的北极星，是我努力想要达到的方向。这么说可能有点奇怪，但在那部剧中看你表演，真的有一种解脱的感觉。确实如此。对我来说，它真的开启了另一片天地，感觉就像是打开了全新的方式，心想：好吧，这条路是可以走的。既然他演得这么不加掩饰，那我们大家也都能蒙混过关了。
Then I can do it. Yeah. I mean, if he's just mumbling and not looking. Yeah. He makes me look like a genius. I mean. A comedy of discomfort and awkward pauses and loss of dignity with just sort of a look or a moment as opposed to jokes or anything like that.
那我也能行。对啊。我的意思是，如果他只是嘴里含糊不清还不看镜头。对。他把我衬托得像个天才。我的意思是。一种充满不适感、尴尬停顿以及通过一个眼神或瞬间失去尊严的喜剧风格，而不是靠什么笑话或诸如此类的东西。
And that the length of those episodes allowed for that kind of that editorial pace too is something that we sort of tried for. I don't think we could with, with our format, but. Well, I think it was lucky the format allowed me to do that with a fake documentary because I was emulating something. I was trying to emulate a very ordinary man who wanted to be famous. So it was sort of, it was easy to not be a trained actor doing that. Do you know what I mean?
而且那些剧集的长度也允许这种剪辑节奏的存在，这也是我们当时极力尝试的。我觉得以我们的形式可能做不到，但……好吧，我觉得很幸运，这种伪纪录片的形式允许我这么做，因为我在模仿某种东西。我当时在模仿一个想出名却极其平凡的男人。所以演一个并非科班出身的演员做这种事，其实挺轻松的。你知道我的意思吗？
Yeah, of course. But what was the genesis? We've never really, I'm sure you've had to explain it before. It was an impression I used to do of like bosses and stuff. I worked in an office for like 10 years. So it was like a Frankenstein of people I'd met growing up. And you suddenly, and I was always, I was always the idiot. I was always trying to make people laugh.
嗯，当然。但最初的灵感是怎么来的？我们从来没有……我确信你以前肯定解释过这事。那是我以前经常模仿老板之类的人。我在办公室工作了大约10年。所以这个角色可以说是我成长过程中遇到的人的“弗兰肯斯坦式”拼凑。而你突然发现，我一直都是那个傻子。我总是试图逗大家笑。
And, you know, I was that guy. I was sort of that guy without ambition or rather without, without nerve. I think I'd lost my nerve. I'd just been a failed musician after like five years of trying. I got a normal job and then I worked my way out to sort of middle management in an office like that. In fact, the little pre-pilot that we shot, I went back to the office I used to work in and I used mates as extras.
而且，你知道的，我就是那种人。我多少是那种缺乏野心、或者说缺乏勇气的人。我觉得我当时已经失去了勇气。在尝试了大约五年后，我成了个失败的音乐人。我找了一份正常的工作，然后在那样的办公室里一路奋斗到了中层管理岗位。事实上，我们拍的那个小型预告片，我回到了我以前工作过的办公室，还找了朋友来当群演。
And I just, I just ad-libbed around this character showing off to the camera. And the seed of that was we had 10 years of these quaint docusopes in the 90s on British TV. The new big thing was docusopes. So we had one called airport. We had one called hotel. We had one called liner. And it was just normal people filmed and they'd become sort of stars for 10 minutes.
我只是……我只是围绕着这个在镜头前爱出风头的角色进行了即兴发挥。而这一切的种子在于，90年代英国电视上有过10年那种古雅的纪录肥皂剧。当时最新的大热趋势就是纪录肥皂剧。所以我们有一个叫《机场》的节目。我们有一个叫《酒店》的节目。我们有一个叫《班轮》的节目。内容就是拍摄普通人，然后他们就会变成某种持续10分钟的明星。
And of course nowadays they become stars forever and make millions. But then it was, that was their 15 minutes of fame and, you know, you wheel them out. So it was ordinary people wanting to be famous. And was it the same type of format? Would they address camera? Would there be testimonials and things like that? Yeah. There was usually a narration as well.
当然，如今他们可以永远当明星并赚几百万了。但在当时，那就是他们成名的15分钟，你知道的，然后你把他们推上台。所以那是渴望出名的普通人。而且是同一种类型的形式吗？他们会直接对着镜头说话吗？会有访谈实录之类的内容吗？对。通常也会有画外音。
But we didn't do that. But there was often, it was things like the cement for the swimming pool was late and they have to open it in an hour. It was stuff like that. Right. Was it sort of a Michael Aptid? Was it inspired by the up series at all? Do you think?
但我们没有用那个。不过经常会有这样的内容：比如游泳池的水泥迟到了，他们必须在一个小时内开业。就是诸如此类的事情。对。它有点像迈克尔·阿普特的风格吗？它有受到《人生七年》系列的启发吗？你觉得呢？
Well, that was, that's the, the greatest. That's incredible. I mean, that's still going. Yeah. Yeah. But that's, that really is beautiful social commentary. Sure. These got watered down, you know, and then people would be doing them because they think, well, I can be famous.
好吧，那真的是，最棒的。太不可思议了。我的意思是，那现在还在进行。是的。是的。但那确实是精彩的社会评论。当然。这些后来都被冲淡了，你知道的，然后人们会去模仿，因为他们觉得，好吧，我可以成名。
Everyone says, I'm a laugh. I'll go on there. And it's like, there was suddenly too much, you know. So then it was people trying to be famous. Right. And so that's what I picked up on with Brent, that he, he was, he was a bit sad. He was forgotten. And he thought, now's my chance.
每个人都说，我很搞笑，我会去那儿。然后就觉得，突然间人太多了，你知道的。所以后来就变成了人们都在试图成名。对的。所以这就是我对布伦特的看法，他，他，他有点难过。他被遗忘了。他觉得，现在是我的机会了。
And it wasn't the fake documentary. It wouldn't work. Yeah. Because once you know why David Brent is acting like that, it's, it's, it's so tangible. It's, it's so great that he just wants to be loved and famous. And it's heartbreaking in a hilarious way. Yeah. I think that one of the things that I, certainly I personally really connect with,
而且这不是那部伪纪录片。那样是行不通的。是的。因为一旦你知道大卫·布伦特为什么会有那种表现，那种感觉就太真实了。太棒了，他只是渴望被爱和成名。这种搞笑的方式让人心碎。是的。我认为其中有一点，我个人确实深有共鸣，
with what you do is, is it that desperation? So many of your characters have this sort of misplaced or just, they're so desperate for whatever it is. It's so funny. It's so funny and sad at the same time that I think the funniest characters and obviously in real life, you know, the documentary aspect of it, we like real life is the most dramatic and the funniest comedy and fiction can only try to emulate all those things in real life. So, but someone trying to be funny and it is successful isn't as funny as someone who
你所做的是那种绝望感吗？你的许多角色都有这种错位的或者说，他们对某种东西是如此绝望。这太有趣了。既有趣又悲伤，我认为最有趣的角色，显然在现实生活中，你知道，纪录片的那种视角，我们喜欢现实生活是最戏剧化也是最好笑的喜剧，而虚构作品只能去努力模仿现实生活中的所有这些。所以，但一个试图搞笑的人如果成功了，也没有一个
doesn't want to be funny and wants to be taken seriously. Right. So my favorite characters for those people that demanded being taken seriously and so, so it undermines everything. Someone being pretentious and then slipping on a banana skin is funnier than a clown slipping on a banana skin because we know the clown doesn't care. Right. He wants to slip away.
不想搞笑，却渴望被严肃对待。对吧。所以，我最喜欢那些要求被严肃对待的人，而这却破坏了一切。一个自命不凡的人踩到香蕉皮滑倒，比一个小丑踩到香蕉皮滑倒要搞笑得多，因为我们知道小丑并不在意。对吧。他就是想滑倒。
So I think when someone wants to be taken seriously or says things like, I am a comedian. That's funny. I remember, I remember getting a letter soon after the office, right, by someone saying writing to get a part and the letter started, dear Mr. Gervais, I am a brilliant actor. And I thought it was signed Sean. Oh, so you got it. You got it because I didn't. I still haven't heard.
所以我想，当有人想要被认真对待，或者说出诸如“我是一名喜剧演员。这很有趣”之类的话时。我记得，我记得在《办公室》开播后不久收到了一封信，对吧，有人写信来想谋求一个角色，信的开头是：亲爱的热维斯先生，我是一个才华横溢的演员。我想那是署名肖恩。哦，所以你懂了。你懂了，因为我没有。我到现在还没听说。
So I don't know if you got it. Yeah. Desperation is funny. Anger is funny. People with no sense of humor is funny. People with no sense of humor is funny. One of the things I think is so admirable about you and there's no question here. So don't feel the need to respond because I know your humility will keep you from doing
所以我不知道你是否理解。是的。绝望很有趣。愤怒很有趣。没有幽默感的人很有趣。没有幽默感的人很有趣。我认为你身上最令人钦佩的一点是，而且这里没有问题。所以不要觉得有必要回应，因为我知道你的谦逊会阻止你这样做
that, but you're all the vulnerability that you put into all the vulnerability that you put into David Bren and many other characters that you play is really the root of the comedy. The man is so broken and a mess inside that that is what I find so heartbreakingly hilarious about it. Yet on your stand up, it is almost the polar opposite of that in that there's so much confidence and judgment is sort of the character that you play. And you can still get equal last with that. So the fact that you're able to make people, you know, double over.
那个，但是你投入到大卫·布伦以及你扮演的许多其他角色身上的所有脆弱感，其实才是喜剧的根源。这个人在内心深处是如此破碎和混乱，这正是我觉得它令人心碎的搞笑之处。然而在你的单口喜剧中，情况几乎完全相反，里面充满了自信，而评判似乎成了你所扮演角色的特点。你依然能用这种方式获得同样的笑果。所以，你能让人笑得前俯后仰。
Well, that's very interesting because I don't think you need stand up slightly different. Stand up is slightly different to fiction in the sense that when you do a sitcom or a film or whatever, you do your best and you're trying to make the plot work and the characters work and you do all that. And then you put it out there and there's nothing you can do about it. With stand up, you do it every night and the audience, it's more like evolution by natural selection because they choose the bits for you. It's more like a science because it either works or it doesn't.
嗯，这非常有趣，因为我认为单口喜剧不需要……其实有点不同。单口喜剧和虚构作品有点不同，因为当你拍情景喜剧、电影或别的什么时，你会尽力让剧情和人物运转起来，你做了所有这些。然后你把它发布出去，你就无能为力了。而对于单口喜剧，你每晚都在表演，观众的反应更像是自然选择演化，因为他们为你挑选了包袱。这更像是一门科学，因为它要么管用，要么不管用。
And by the end, you've got everything that works every night to everyone around the world because it's tried and tested. They've chosen it for you. So that's slightly different. So what you don't want with stand up is an audience to feel sorry for you because you haven't got time. You don't want that. No, you don't want that.
最后，你拥有了每晚都能对全世界所有人起作用的一切，因为它是经过尝试和考验的。他们为你选择了它。所以这有点不同。因此，单口喜剧最不需要的是让观众同情你，因为你没有时间。你不需要那个。不，你不需要那个。
No, because it's the purest desire because jokes are more of an intellectual pursuit. You don't really need a context for jokes, again, because they work or they don't. A joke can sort of work on the page. You can read a joke and it still works. You don't need someone telling it. Obviously, you add to that. I think my favorite stand ups do add to that. They've got a context.
不，因为它是最纯粹的欲望，因为笑话更像是一种智力追求。你其实不需要为笑话设定语境，同样是因为它们要么管用，要么不管用。笑话在纸面上也能发挥某种作用。你可以读一个笑话，它依然好笑。你不需要别人来讲它。显然，你给它增色了。我认为我最喜欢的单口喜剧演员确实给它增色了。他们有自己的语境。
They build character. You've got props. Yeah. Props in a bag. Sure. Those are your favorite snaps. You love a prop comic. Be honest.
它们塑造性格。你有道具。是的。袋子里的道具。当然。那是你最喜欢的快照。你喜欢道具喜剧演员。老实说。
You are being humble here. What I'm trying to say is that the comedic flavor, your comedy comes from vulnerability, let's say, and David Brent. But with the stand up, it comes from sort of this feigned, brash arrogance. And that you're able to do both so well, I find just incredible. Well, that's just because it's another character and you commit to it. And that evolves as well. But you can't just write a bunch of jokes and anybody can say them and they're going
你在这里太谦虚了。我想说的是，你的喜剧风味，你的喜剧很大程度上来自于脆弱感，比如大卫·布伦特。但在单口喜剧中，它来自于那种假装的、无礼的傲慢。你能把这两种风格都演得这么好，我觉得简直不可思议。嗯，那只是因为那是另一个角色，而且你全身心投入其中。而且它也在不断发展。但你不能只是写一堆笑话让任何人都能讲，然后它们就会
to get the same laugh. No, but you can because, like, by the time humanity came around, I sort of hit that sweet spot where the audience had known me for 15 years. So they knew what I was doing. They knew the irony. They understood the nuance without me having to explain it. So I could come out and hit the ground running. The important thing is this, behind the scenes, right, I think with particularly stand up,
为了得到同样的笑声。不，但你可以，因为，比如说，当人类出现的时候，我差不多达到了那个最佳状态，观众已经认识我15年了。所以他们知道我在做什么。他们知道其中的讽刺。他们理解其中的微妙之处，而不需要我解释。所以我一上台就能迅速进入状态。重要的是，在幕后，对吧，我认为特别是单口喜剧，
is traditionally it's a low status thing. We're a court jester, we go out there with the other peasants and we tease the king. OK. And everyone knows what comedians earn these days. So I can't really go out there and pretend to be struggling, right? I think that would be nauseating and dishonest. I would like to see you try, though. Yeah.
传统上，喜剧演员是个地位较低的职业。我们就像宫廷小丑，和其他农夫一起去嘲弄国王。好吧。而且大家都知道现在喜剧演员赚多少钱。所以我不能再装作生活窘迫的样子了，对吧？我觉得那样会让人恶心而且不诚实。不过，我还真想看你试一下。是啊。
So I keep my low status in two ways. One, I invite them behind the curtain. I say, what, you think it's plain saving? Do your being rich? Well, look what happened to me when I met so-and-so or the first time I took a private jet, they thought I was the cook. So I do all that, right? Right.
所以，我通过两种方式来保持我的低地位。第一，我让他们来到幕后。我说，什么，你以为这很简单吗？你以为你有钱吗？好吧，看看我遇到某某人时发生了什么，或者我第一次坐私人飞机时，他们以为我是厨师。所以，我做了所有这些，对吧？没错。
And the other way I do it is I talk about things where I'm worse off than them. I talk about being fat and old and in pain and going bald. And do you know what I mean? I'm being hated by the press. I don't know what you mean. I don't know what you mean. But let me, do you think, I mean, Ricky, you started as a, you were doing stand up before, right? You'd been doing stand up off and on, yeah, for years.
另一个方法是聊聊我比他们惨的地方。我聊自己又胖又老、浑身是痛、日渐秃顶。你知道我的意思吗？我被媒体痛恨。我不知道你是什么意思。我不知道你是什么意思。不过等等，你觉得，我的意思是，瑞奇，你一开始，你之前做过单口喜剧，对吧？你断断续续做过单口喜剧，是的，好多年了。
No, I started before the office, but I only started in about 1999, I'd say, was my first try. And then you started doing that in 99. Then the office hits. And then over the last 10 years or 15 years as you've grown and done more and more stand up, you kind of, you build that currency, right, with your audience. Like that, that's the thing. You build the momentum of that sort of relationship that you have. Yeah, I have to go out there and I want to be the one that says the wrong thing.
不，我在《办公室》之前就开始了，但我大概在1999年左右才开始，我可以说那是我的第一次尝试。然后你在99年开始做那个。接着《办公室》大火。在过去的10年或15年里，随着你的成长和越来越多的单口喜剧表演，你建立了一种资本，对吧，与观众之间的资本。就像那样，这就是关键所在。你积累了那种关系的势头。是的，我必须走出去，我想成为那个说错话的人。
Whatever the current regime is, I have to say the wrong thing. I have to go against the grain, which is why it was hard for the last sort of few years. You know, I didn't realize half the people would agree with those things on face value. So irony was put in danger recently. I remember going to that small little theater, you were working stuff out. Remember like a couple of years ago, I came up there and you were working out jokes in the audience. And I remember you, first of all, the relationship was they knew you. They came because they were huge fans.
不管现在的体制是什么，我都得说不对劲的话。我得逆流而上，这就是为什么过去这几年很难熬。你知道的，我没意识到半数的人表面上会同意那些观点。所以讽刺最近陷入了危险之中。我记得去那个小剧场时，你在打磨东西。记得大约几年前，我到那儿去，你在观众面前打磨笑话。我记得你，首先，那种关系是他们认识你。他们来是因为他们是超级粉丝。
You had a limited number of seats. It was basically free, but you were working stuff out. And the relationship was, hey, I'm trying stuff and some stuff was, you know, over the line for them or whatever, but you were figuring out. Well, that's the thing. You know, you do have to find the funny, but you have to go for it. You have to be able to play. And that's the problem again with today as well, because I've done shows that I'm trying stuff out
你们当时只有限量的座位。基本上是免费的，但你们在摸索东西。那种关系是，嘿，我在尝试一些新东西，有些东西对他们来说可能有点过界了之类的，但你们在不断琢磨。这就是关键所在。你知道，你确实得找到笑点，但你必须全力以赴。你得能放得开。这也是当今的问题所在，因为我做过的节目也都在尝试新东西。
and there's been reviewed. And I'm going to go, well, that's mad. You can't do that. You can't do someone who's just started a painting, going, it's rubbish. I haven't done it yet. I've just done the back. You know, it's crazy. So you have to fight against that.
并且已经经过了审核。我要去说，嗯，太疯狂了。你不能那样做。你不能对一个刚开始画画的人说，这真是垃圾。我还没画完呢。我才刚画了背面。你知道的，这太疯狂了。所以你必须与之抗争。
And I try and keep politics, exclusive politics out of comedy. Because I think if you're relying on the audience agreeing with you and getting around applause, it loses something comedically. I want my jokes to be liked. I don't care whether they're right-wing or left-wing or whatever, right? Because the joke either works or it doesn't. And it actually shouldn't matter. It's meaningless anyway nowadays, left and right-wing.
我尽量把政治，纯粹的政治排除在喜剧之外。因为我认为，如果你指望观众赞同你并赢得掌声，喜剧就会失去一些东西。我希望我的笑话能受欢迎。我不在乎它们是右翼的、左翼的还是别的什么，对吧？因为笑话要么好笑，要么不好笑。实际上这根本不重要。现在左右翼已经毫无意义了。
It's a meaningless term. But I think it's important that you evolve, but not with those reasons. You don't evolve because it might be taken the wrong way. You don't evolve because you might be bullied by a reviewer. You don't evolve because you want everyone to like it. That gets you nowhere. When did that happen for you? Because that's a certain fearlessness that I think you have to achieve.
这是一个毫无意义的词。但我认为不断演变是很重要的，但不是出于那些原因。你不会因为可能被误解而去演变。你不会因为可能被评论家欺负而去演变。你不会因为想让所有人都喜欢它而去演变。那样做是行不通的。这在什么时候对你发生过？因为我认为你必须达到那种无畏的境界。
I'm sure there's part of you when you're much younger that you didn't have that, right? I've probably got more fear now, but you have to fight it. You have to know that art is being brave. It is being brave and putting out there. Because you've got more to lose now, right? Well, it just makes me angry. It makes me angry if people don't get something or... So that makes me work harder to still get the same joke out there and everyone like it
我确信当你年轻得多的时候，你身上有一部分是没有这种感觉的，对吧？我现在可能有了更多的恐惧，但你必须去对抗它。你必须知道艺术就是勇敢。这就是勇敢并把它展现出来。因为你现在失去的更多了，对吧？嗯，这只会让我生气。如果人们不理解某些东西或者……这会让我生气。所以这让我更加努力地去把同样的笑话表达出来，并让每个人都喜欢它
and be able to defend it and sleep at night, which I always have done. There's this myth that I go out there and I say what I want and I don't care about what people think of me. That's just not true. It's ahead of a challenge to... I do love it what you do say at the end of it. I don't care, you know. Yeah, of course.
并且能够为之辩护并安然入眠，我一直都是这么做的。有一种说法认为我总是随心所欲地发言，不在乎别人怎么看我，这其实并非事实。这确实是一个挑战……我确实很喜欢你最后说的那句话。我不在乎，你知道的。是的，当然。
I love that. And that's marketing. And you have to be militant about it. You have to act right. You don't care. Right. But actually, you know, it annoys me when, you know, any sort of someone thinks that you've done this or you've gone too far
我太喜欢了。这就是营销。你必须为此据理力争、态度坚决。你必须举止得体，毫不在意。对。但实际上，你知道，当有人觉得你做过头了或者走得太远了，这其实挺让我恼火的。
or I want to go, well, I've worked that joke for a year with like hundreds of thousands of people. You've thought about it for three seconds and you've got it wrong. Right. I think because reviews now are so fast and people don't think there's no nuance on social media. Like, 10 years ago, like 20 years ago, if someone complained about something, it would make me think I'd go, oh, God, you know, really?
或者我想说，好吧，这个笑话我已经打磨了一年，在几十万人面前演过。你只思考了三秒钟，就理解错了。没错。我觉得现在的评论太快了，人们不加思考，社交媒体上没有任何细微的差别。就像10年前，20年前，如果有人抱怨什么事，会让我陷入思考，我会想，天哪，真的吗？
Now someone says I'm offended. I go, yeah, of course you are. Everyone is. It doesn't matter. Yeah, I brought this up before that you have that great tweet that's been shared millions of times, I think now, would you say? Just because you're offended doesn't mean you're right. I know.
现在有人说我被冒犯了。我说，是的，当然你是。每个人都是。这没关系。是的，我之前提过，你有一条很棒的推文，我想现在已经被转发了数百万次，你会这么说吗？仅仅因为你被冒犯了并不意味着你是对的。我知道。
People even understand that and they still fall for it. They still think, no, this is different. I did a tweet when I was doing the warm-up for this new show. I said, guys, are there any things I should never joke about? And of course, everything people said was funny. Everything people said was funny. This disease is things that one person said, losing two children, which I thought was just an amazing thing to tweet.
人们甚至明白这一点，却还是会中计。他们仍然觉得，不，这次情况不同。我在为这个新节目做暖场的时候发了一条推文。我说，各位，有什么是我绝对不能拿来开玩笑的吗？当然，大家说的所有内容都很好笑。大家说的所有内容都很好笑。这种病态的情况是，有个人说，失去两个孩子，我觉得发这样一条推文真是太惊人了。
Just an amazing thing. As opposed to one? Yeah. So specific. So specific. It's sadder than one, but funnier than three. I mean, that's a definite for sure. I remember, I said something similar years ago on Twitter,
真是件不可思议的事。相比于一个呢？对。太具体了。太具体了。比一个更悲伤，但比三个更好笑。我的意思是，这绝对是肯定的。我记得，几年前我在推特上说过类似的话，
but something along the lines, like, apropos of nothing, like, I hope you're not offended. And all these people immediately got on me. A few people sort of saying, like, well, what is it you're talking about? They were pre-offended. Yeah. And I hadn't even said anything.
但大致意思是，像那种莫名其妙地来一句，希望你别介意。然后所有人立刻就找我麻烦了。少数人会问，你到底在说什么？他们还没听到内容就已经先被冒犯了。对。而我甚至什么都还没说。
Yeah. Yeah. Of course. Yeah. So you're right. It's watered it down. Who gives a shit? Twitter is, like, reading every toilet wall in the world, OK?
对。对。当然。对。所以你是对的。它被淡化了。谁在乎呢？推特就像是在阅读世界上每一个厕所的墙壁，好吗？
And when you look at it like that, you shouldn't ever be offended by anything on Twitter. But it also depends on the messenger. Like, I think you are a messenger of that. Like you said, like, it's all branding and marketing. That's who you are. It's kind of like Don Rickles, who I thought was always hilarious. He was so offensive to everybody he met.
从这个角度来看，你绝不应该被推特上的任何东西所冒犯。但这也取决于传达信息的人。比如，我认为你就是这样一个人。就像你说的，这一切都是品牌和营销。这就是你的本质。这有点像唐·里克斯，我一直觉得他非常搞笑。他对遇到的每个人都充满冒犯。
But because it was Don, it was almost OK. But if it's somebody else trying, it's not going to work. Well, that's the other thing as well. It's like, I'm offended when a comedian says sorry. Right. Because it usually means, thank God, a film coming out or something. The last big venue stand-up I went to was you
但是因为是唐，这几乎是可以接受的。但如果是别人来尝试，那是行不通的。哎，这也是另一回事。就好像是，当一个喜剧演员说对不起时，我벼感到冒犯。对吧。因为它通常意味着，感谢上帝，有电影要上映了之类的。我去看的最后一场大型连皇喜剧表演就是你
at the Hollywood Highland. I don't know how many years ago. That business of big venue for stand-ups. Ricky would text me from time to time on his way to an arena. I was like, God, 18,000 tonight. I don't even know. It's a big number. Sorry, I've got to go.
在好莱坞高地。我不知道是多少年前了。那种大型场地的单口喜剧。瑞奇有时会在去体育馆的路上给我发短信。我当时想，天哪，今晚一万八千人。我甚至不知道。这是个庞大的数字。抱歉，我得走了。
Lost perspective. 18,000 people are waiting. Sorry, I've got to dash. Wait, Ricky, can I ask you something? Because I don't know if I'm... I hope I get to see you again. I just... So far, it's not looking great.
失去了方向感。有1.8万人还在等着呢。对不起，我得赶快走了。等等，瑞奇，我能问你个问题吗？因为我不知道我是不是……我希望能再见到你。我只是……到目前为止，情况看起来不太妙。
It's not going to look good. I think you're brilliant. But, you know, I always wanted to ask you, like... I always find it interesting. You and I share several things in common. I started out really early wanting to be a pop star like you. But you kind of succeeded with an album and everything. And we're both gay, right?
这看起来不会太好。我觉得你很才华横溢。不过，你知道，我一直想问你，比如……我一直觉得很有趣。你和我有很多共同点。我从很小的时候就想像你一样成为一名流行歌星。但你凭借一张专辑成功了，诸如此类。而且我们都是同性恋，对吧？
Sure. I don't think he was ready for that. I don't think he was ready for that. It's not this podcast. This episode is about to go huge. We've both slept with Bainman. We're guys. And live to tell about it.
当然。我觉得他对此还没有准备好。我觉得他对此还没有准备好。这不是这个播客。这一期节目要火了。我们都和贝恩曼睡过。我们是男人。而且还活着把这事说出来。
Podcast. No, but... Can I go and get a beer? Oh. Yeah, go get a beer. Hang on. Let him go and get a beer. Okay, good.
播客。不，不过……我能去拿杯啤酒吗？哦。行，去拿杯啤酒吧。等等。让他去拿杯啤酒吧。好吧，太好了。
Hey, JB, what happened to your hand? Oh, I was pulling my golf bag out of the backseat of my Tesla. Oh, God. Is that way? Is all of that true so far? Jesus. And I sprained the tip of my ring finger. Yes.
嘿，JB，你的手怎么了？哦，我把高尔夫球包从特斯拉后座拉出来时弄的。哦，天哪。到目前为止，这些都是真的吗？天呐。我把无名指的指尖给扭伤了。对。
Well, I'm glad you got your ale. So maybe we can get back to my question about music. I'm sorry. So listen. Jesus. Sean. Keep us on the rails, Sean. I'm actually interested just because I find it interesting that you were also very
好吧，很高兴你拿到了啤酒。那我们能回到我关于音乐的问题上吗？对不起。听着。天呐。肖恩。稳住我们，肖恩。其实我挺感兴趣的，因为我觉得很有意思，你以前也……
seriously, like I've seen those music videos and I just thought it was interesting that you pursued that. And were you all in on that? And then it didn't work out. Or were you pursuing that and acting at the same time or whatever made you famous? You know, and then you had... All in. Yeah, all in.
说真的，就像我看过那些音乐录影带，我只是觉得有意思，你竟然追求过那个。而且你当时是全心投入吗？然后没成功。还是说你当时一边搞音乐一边演戏，或者说是什么让你出了名？你知道的，然后你……全心投入。对，全心投入。
But in retrospect, did it all wrong? I was in a band. Because I love those songs, by the way. Thank you. It was very fast. It came and went very, very quickly. And I think you only know about it now because I'm famous for something else. And those pictures and videos pop up on Jimmy Fallon.
但回想起来，是不是全盘皆错？我组过乐队。因为顺便说一句，我很喜欢那些歌。谢谢。那段经历非常短暂。来得快，去得也极快。我想你们现在知道这事，只是因为我因为别的事出了名。那些照片和视频还在吉米·法伦的节目里出现过。
So like anyone else in every generation, I think it was... Yeah, I found it fascinating because I was pursuing the same thing and I also then went into comedy. Well, okay. So it started at college and we did a demo tape and we got signed and we did two singles and then we were dropped. And it was like, it started and finished within a year. And that was it.
所以就像每一代人中的其他人一样，我觉得那是……对，我觉得这很迷人，因为我也在追求同样的事情，后来我也去说单口喜剧了。好吧，好吧。所以在大学时我们录了一盘小样，然后签约了，出了两张单曲，接着就被解约了。就像这样，在一年内开始又结束，然后就那样了。
Oh, wow. And I think even if it had been a success then, in 1984, whatever it was, it would still have been over quickly. But there are some bands that were good back then that are still around. And would you and Rick Astley have done a duet? Do you think you and Rick would have... It would have been... Wham, or...
哦，哇。我想，即使它当时在1984年或者别的什么年份成功了，也还是会很快结束的。不过有些当年的好乐队到现在还在。你和里克·阿斯利会合唱一曲吗？你觉得你和里克会……那会是……威猛乐队，还是……
It would have certainly been... You know, we started with the sort of the hair and makeup and synth pop. But this is the mistake I made. The mistake I made was I wanted to be a pop star and I should have wanted to be a musician. And when I started doing this, I realized that, you know, I consciously and militantly called myself a writer-director. So people didn't think that I just wanted to be on telly because I didn't. And I came to it very wary.
那肯定会是……你知道的，我们一开始走的是那种发型、妆容和合成器流行乐路线。但我犯的错误是。我犯的错误是，我当时想成为一个流行歌星，而我本该想成为一个音乐家的。当我开始做这个时，我意识到，你知道的，我有意识且强硬地称自己为主演兼编剧。这样人们就不会以为我只是想上电视，因为我并不想。我对这行一直非常警惕。
I came to this very, very wary, not because of the music thing, but because of, I think, the press in England. And I never revere fame. I've never asked for an autograph. I've never been impressed by seeing a famous... And I thought that of myself. I thought the people I admire, I admire because they've done something absolutely brilliant. My heroes are like scientists and things like that.
我对这一切非常非常警惕，不是因为音乐的事，而是因为英国的媒体，我想。我从不盲目崇拜名气。我从未索要过签名。我从未对看到某个名人感到……我自己也是这么想的。我崇拜的人，我崇拜他们是因为他们做出了绝对出色的成就。我的偶像就像科学家之类的人。
And Andrew Ridgely. Yeah, exactly. So I feared fame. I didn't want to... I didn't sign that deal with the devil. It made me famous and you can go through my bins. In fact, I probably feared it too much. I thought it would be too minute that now I'm sort of chilled and it's fine, you know.
还有安德鲁·Ridgeley。对，没错。所以我害怕名气。我不想……我没有跟恶魔做那种交易。它让我出了名，而你可以去翻我的垃圾桶。事实上，我可能对它恐惧过头了。我以为那会是细致入微的监视，现在我算是看开了，觉得也没事，你知道的。
But don't you think people that have fame wanted it? What, to a certain degree, yeah. But the other thing is, it's a bit ambiguous when you're an actor, isn't it? Because I think you're allowed to really want to be an actor because it's fun and it's great and it's interesting and it's better than most jobs. Without saying, I want to be famous. I think it can be... Because if you're a successful actor, you're probably a famous actor.
但你不觉得那些出名的人本身就想要名气吗？什么，在某种程度上是的。但另一件事是，当你是个演员时，情况有点暧昧，对吧？因为我觉得你可以真的很想当演员，因为它很有趣、很棒、很有意思，而且比大多数工作都好。不用非得说：我想出名。我觉得这可以……因为如果你是个成功的演员，你很可能也是个著名的演员。
And certainly, there was easier routes to being an actor than actually writing and directing a sitcom for three years. There's easier routes. In fact, it annoyed me once when the office broke and it seemed like I was just famous overnight without all the work. Someone on the red carpet said to me, and what advice would you give anyone else who wants to be famous like you? And I said, go out and kill a prostitute.
而且显而易见，成为演员比实实在在地花三年时间写一部情景喜剧并自己导演，有更轻松的途径。有更轻松的捷径。事实上，有一次《办公室》大火，看起来我好像一夜成名，没费什么力气，这让我很恼火。红毯上有个人对我说：“你会给其他想跟你一样出名的人什么建议？”我说：“出去杀个妓女。”
And they looked to me like I was mental. It just really annoyed me. Like, there's such easier ways to be famous than actually writing a sitcom from scratch. Right, right. Do offers come to you when you kind of flirt with that, or do you only create your own things and only want to create your own things? I think the offers have dried up because it's been no for, like, ten years
他们看着我，就像我是个疯子。这真的让我很抓狂。就像，明明有那么多比从头编写一部情景喜剧轻松得多成名方式。对，对。当你稍微涉足一下时，会有片约找上门吗？还是说你只创作自己的东西，并且只想创作自己的东西？我觉得片约已经变少了，因为大约有十年都在说不。
that I've usually been busy, and you start off in your flat. And I remember, I think, the second episode of The Office had gone out in, like, 2001. And my agent got a call from a studio making this movie, and they sent me the script, and I said, what part am I? And they said, the lead. And I said, it says here he's 26, right? And I was 39 at the time, sort of 40. And they went, we can change that.
我通常都很忙，而这一切始于我的公寓。我记得，好像是《办公室》第二集在2001年左右播出后。我的经纪人接到了一家拍电影的制片厂的电话，他们把剧本发给了我，我说：“我演哪个角色？”他们说：“主角。”我说：“这里写着他26岁，对吧？”我当时39岁，快40岁了。他们说：“我们可以改。”
And I thought, OK. And I said, I think you need, I said, who's going to go and see this? No one knows me. And they went, quiet. And I went, you need John Cusack for this. And they sort of went, OK, well, thanks for the call. And in my head, I was oozing integrity. And they were going, what a guy.
我想，好吧。我说，我觉得你们需要，我说：“谁会来看这个？没人认识我。”他们沉默了。我说：“你们这得找约翰·库萨克。”他们差不多就说：“好吧，谢谢来电。”在我的脑海里，我浑身散发着正直的光芒。而他们则在想：“这人真奇葩。”
But actually, they probably went, what a fucking idiot. Who do you think he is, turning down the lead movie? He's not going to get out of there. That's interesting. So it was no because I was busy. It was no all the way. The first one that I said yes to, because I read it, the first one I read, actually, Jane would read them and say, no, no, no.
但实际上，他们可能在想：“这他妈是个白痴。他以为他是谁，竟然拒绝电影男主角？他以后别想混了。”这很有趣。所以拒绝是因为我很忙。是一路都在拒绝。我答应接拍的第一个剧本，因为我读了——其实第一个剧本是我读的，简会读那些剧本然后说，不，不，不。
And the first one I did that I thought, if I don't do this, I'll never do one, was Ghost Town. And it just, I was reading it and I was laughing. I thought, this is me. Yeah, I loved it. I loved that one. This is written for me. And so I did it and I loved it.
我拍的第一个让我觉得“如果我不拍这个，我这辈子都不会拍电影了”的作品是《鬼镇》。我当时一边读一边笑，心想，这就是我。对，我很喜欢。我非常喜欢那部。这就是为我写的。所以我拍了，而且我很喜欢。
But it still doesn't feel like mine. The things, I've done loads of things. I've popped up in things. I've done the Golden Globes. I've done this and that. But if I'll say, what have you done? I blissed, you know, three or four sitcoms, a couple of movies and my stand-up. That's what I'd say was mine.
但它仍然不觉得完全属于我。这些东西，我拍过很多。我在各种节目里露过面。我主持过金球奖。这啊那啊我都做过。但如果有人问我：“你都拍过什么？”我会列举，你知道的，三四部情景喜剧、几部电影和我的单口喜剧。那才是我会称之为属于我的东西。
Right, right. Do you know what I mean? Is Jane your filter of pretty much like a she or go to barometer of everything? Yeah, now I don't even, I say no to everything because I'm sort of busy. But when I'm working stuff out, yeah, I run things by, if I go for a run and I've got an idea for a routine, I come back and I say, what do you think of this? And she says, please don't do that.
对，对。你知道我的意思吗？简基本上就是你的过滤器，或者说是你所有事情的晴雨表吗？对，现在我甚至都不……我对所有事情都说不，因为我挺忙的。但当我在构思作品时，对，我会找人商量。如果我去跑步，脑子里冒出了一个新段子的想法，我回来就会说：“你觉得这个怎么样？”她说：“请别讲那个。”
And I know it's, I know it's good. I know, I know. I love how many times we've been fucking around or having dinner or whatever and how many times Jane has said, you guys have to keep your voice down. Shut the window. Shut the window. I have one more question about the office. So it was an incredible success on its own.
我就知道，我知道这个点子很好。我懂，我懂。我太喜欢我们有多少次在瞎胡闹、吃晚饭或者干别的什么时，简说了多少次“你们俩声音小点。把窗户关上。把窗户关上”。我还有一个关于《办公室》的问题。所以它本身取得了难以置信的成功。
And then when it got brought here to America, another incredible success and feather in your cap with that, was it comfortable or uncomfortable to watch it take its, I don't know, necessary or unnecessary, slight comedic tone shift to an American pacing and whatnot? You've got to think that it's not your baby. You think that, you know. Ricky, just include in that, because I was sort of going off with Jason saying, it was such a huge shift.
然后当它被带到美国来时，又取得了难以置信的成功，为你赢得了又一枚勋章。看着它走向美国式的节奏及其他方面，做出这种必要的或不必要的轻微喜剧基调转变，你是感到舒服还是不舒服？你得这么想，它已经不是你的孩子了。你会这么想，你知道的。瑞奇，把它也算进去，因为我刚才顺着杰森的话说，这真是一个巨大的转变。
When you see, it changed the way certainly in this country, people started making comedies for sure. There was such a direct effect. I remember watching somebody on a very famous, who created a very famous successful sitcom here saying, you know, and then we decided in the pilot, why not have the characters talk to the camera? And I thought, shut up. Well, the thing is I didn't invent the genre.
当你看到它改变了人们制作喜剧的方式，绝对改变了，尤其是在这个国家。它的影响是如此直接。我记得看到一个非常著名的人，在这里创作了一部非常著名且成功的情景喜剧的人说：“你知道，后来我们在试播集里决定，为什么不让角色对着镜头说话呢？”我心想，闭嘴吧。好吧，问题是我并没有发明这种流派。
In fact, my biggest influence, I think, right in it, there was someone else's work with Spinal Tap, which is a fake documentary. That's just, I mean, that's no one owns fake documentary. I suppose what was different, slightly different about it was that it was, we left the boring bits in, like David Brent made bad jokes and no one laughed. I wanted that, I want to explore that gap, that social, because that's the worst thing for me. I don't get embarrassed, but I get embarrassed for other people.
事实上，我认为我最大的影响，在其中，有别人的作品《摇滚万岁》，那是一部伪纪录片。那只是——我的意思是，没有人拥有伪纪录片。我想它稍微有点不同的是，我们把无聊的部分保留了下来，比如大卫·布伦特开了个烂玩笑，而没有人笑。我想要那个，我想探索那个空隙，那个社交空隙，因为对我来说那是糟糕透顶的事。我不会感到尴尬，但我会为别人感到尴尬。
If we're in a group and someone makes a bad joke and no one laughs, I just want to go back in time and go, right, do it like this. Let's do this again. Ricky, what you guys did so well on the show, and I remember this kind of reminds me of when Mitch Hurwitz was putting together the pilot of Arrested. What you've done so well is... Anyone listening to Arrested is short for Arrested Development. It's a TV show.
如果我们在一群人当中，有人开了个烂玩笑，没有人笑，我只想回到过去说：“行，学我这样。我们再来一次。”瑞奇，你们在这部节目里表现得非常出色，这让我想起米奇·赫维茨在制作《发展受阻》的试播集时……你们做得非常出色的是……任何在听的人，“发展”是《发展受阻》的简称。那是一部电视剧。
He just, he leaves off the last word. It's just, we haven't got, there's limited time. I've worked out that if we said Arrested Development every time, it'd be three months of our life. Great, now we've got to go cut that out. By the way, Ricky has called me on that out loud in Arrested. Arrested Development. But what you did, such a great job is, when you put that show together,
他只是，他省掉了最后一个词。只是，我们没有，时间有限。我算过，如果我们每次都说《发展受阻》，那将占用我们生活中三个月的时间。太好了，现在我们得把这段剪掉了。顺便说一句，瑞奇刚才大声指出了我这一点，在《发展受阻》里。——《发展受阻》。但你们做得非常棒的一点是，当你们把那部剧组合在一起时，
you recognized you'd have David Brent do the worst joke or do something super embarrassing, and then you always made sure to anchor that by looking at the reactions of the people around him. You whip hand or whatever, and that's what happened. I remember with Arrested, hang on, Development. But that Mitch said that when he was putting the pilot together of Arrested Development that he had...
你们意识到会让大卫·布伦特讲最烂的笑话，或者做一些超级尴尬的事，然后你们总是确保通过观察他周围人的反应来稳住这个画面。你用鞭子手势还是什么的，结果就是这样。我记得拍《发展受阻》时，等等，发展。但米奇说过，当他在制作《发展受阻》的试播集时，他……
He was like, it's not working. And he realized that he needed to have all these crazy characters do stuff, and he needed to see Jason's reaction to it, because that put it in the context. Well, that to me is the comedy. Someone doing something weird is one part of it. But how does it fall? What's the fallout of it?
他当时觉得：这样行不通。他意识到他需要让所有这些疯狂的角色去做各种事情，而他必须看到杰森对这些事情的反应，因为这赋予了它语境。好吧，对我来说，这就是喜剧。某人做奇怪的事只是一部分。但结果如何？后续影响是什么？
That's what's always interesting to me. And again, I learned that from Laurel and Hardy. So Stan doing something stupid was funny, but it affecting Ollie was the joke for me. That's what comedy some company didn't have before that. There was no fallout. No one got hurt in the wake of someone doing something ridiculous. People would be acting, and they'd be saying something weird,
这才是最吸引我的地方。再说一次，我是从劳莱和哈迪那里学到这一点的。所以斯坦做蠢事很好笑，但它对奥利产生的影响对我来说才是笑点。这就是以前某些喜剧没有的东西。没有后续影响。在有人做出荒谬的事情之后，没有人受伤。人们在演戏，他们会说一些奇怪的话，
but they'd be acting like he said something normal. So you have to react to that. Well, there's nothing weird about Martians on Mars. You put a Martian on Earth. That's interesting. Well, that's another very good point, because that's why, again, David Brent was the boss. And so he shouldn't have been acting like that.
但他们演得好像他说的话很正常一样。所以你必须对此做出反应。好吧，火星上有火星人一点也不奇怪。你把一个火星人放到地球上。这就很有趣了。好吧，这也是非常重要的一点，因为这就是为什么，同样地，大卫·布伦特是老板。所以他不应该那样行事。
He should have been the grown-up, but he was acting like a child. So again, the big thing there was men as boys and women as adults, which, again, I think is reflected. But again, Laurel and Hardy did that. Laurel and Hardy, they were children, and their wives had to catch them doing naughty things. Who was it that said steal from the best? And I certainly have in Laurel and Hardy and Chris Guest and those guys.
他本该是个成年人，但他却像个孩子一样行事。所以再次强调，那里最大的核心是男人如男孩，女人如成年人，我觉得这再次得到了呼应。但劳莱和哈迪也这么做过。劳莱和哈迪，他们就像小孩子，他们的妻子不得不抓住他们在做淘气的事情。是谁说过“向最优秀的人偷师”？我当然在劳莱和哈迪、克里斯·盖斯特以及那些人身上学到了这一点。
So, Ricky, what do you... Because I'm like, this is going to be over, and then... And he'll never talk to you again. And we're going to go there after. And in my mind, you go off and you start writing and creating and doing all of these things. But what is the reality? Like, what does your days consist of?
所以，瑞奇，你……因为我在想，这就要结束了，然后……他再也不会跟你说话了。我们待会儿要去那里。在我的脑海里，你会去写剧本、进行创作并做所有这些事情。但现实是什么样的呢？比如，你的一天都是怎么过的？
What do you do? Like, what will you do tonight? I'll go and watch... Arrest her. Arrest her. A Scandi Noir serial killer or spy thriller on Netflix or Amazon Prime or Walter Presents or BBC Four. I want European or Middle Eastern or South American drama. I've just found now that with all these subscripts, I can find the best dramas in the world.
你都在做什么？比如，你今晚要做什么？我要去看……逮捕她。逮捕她。Netflix或Amazon Prime、Walter Presents或BBC Four上的北欧黑色连环杀手剧或间谍惊悚片。我想要欧洲、中东或南美洲的剧集。我刚刚发现，有了所有这些订阅服务，我能找到世界上最棒的剧集。
Why don't you be in one? Yeah. Because I can't speak any languages. And also... What about English? I see my favourite thing, right? This Scandi drama is like series three, and suddenly an Englishman or an American pops up
你怎么不参演一个？对啊。因为我不会说任何语言。而且还有……英语呢？我看到我最喜欢的东西了，对吧？这些北欧剧演到第三季左右，突然一个英国人或美国人冒了出来，
and I go, oh, fucking hell. They just ruin it. Yeah. They just fucking ruin it. Have you watched Long Greenage, otherwise known as Spiral, that French cop show? It might be one of the best programs ever. Me too.
我就想：哦，他妈的见鬼。他们直接把剧给毁了。对。他们他妈的直接给毁了。你看过《法国刑警局》（又名《螺旋》）那部法国警匪剧吗？它可能是史上最好的节目之一。我也是。
It's amazing. Another one as well. There's only one thing that might even be better than that, and that's the Bureau. Have you seen it, the Bureau? Of course, it's incredible. It's incredible. It's incredible.
太棒了。还有另一个。甚至可能比那个还要好，那就是《传奇办公室》。你看过吗，《传奇办公室》？当然，太棒了。太棒了。太棒了。
There's a great Belgian show as well called The Break. Have you seen about this? Amazing. Have you seen... Oh, the 12, another Belgian thing. The 12th. The 12th. Oh, my God.
还有一部很棒的比利时剧叫《破案》。你看过这个吗？太棒了。你看过……哦，《十二怒汉》（编者注：应为比利时剧《审判的第12人》），另一部比利时剧。《十二个人》。《十二个人》。哦，天哪。
Wait, did you... Have you guys seen Quincy? Yeah. And what about Chicago Fire, guys? These guys... Jason spends all this time trying to figure out how IPA is made, so he doesn't have time to watch. Well, that's...
等等，你……你们看过《昆西》吗？对。还有《芝加哥烈焰》呢，伙计们？这些人……杰森花了大把时间琢磨IPA（印度淡色艾尔）啤酒是怎么酿造的，所以他没时间看剧。好吧，那是……
So, OK, to quickly answer, I get up, I have a coffee, breakfast. We go for a long walk, which is habit now. We get that where we used to do that when we were allowed to go out one hour in lockdowns. With dogs, cats? I know your pickle. You don't walk a cat, you stupid ass.
所以，好吧，简单回答一下，我起床，喝杯咖啡，吃早餐。我们去进行长距离散步，这现在已经成了一种习惯。我们养成了这个习惯，以前在封城期间被允许出门一小时的时候我们就这么干。带着狗，还是猫？我知道你那点事。你不会遛猫的，你这个笨蛋。
Well, my cat died at the beginning of the lockdown. We just got a new one. Oh, you see what you've done, Sean? Where'd it go, Sean? You fucking dick. Go on, sorry. So you're walking the cat? No, we go for a walk.
好吧，我的猫在封城刚开始时死了。我们刚养了一只新的。哦，你看你干了什么，肖恩？它去哪儿了，肖恩？你这个混蛋。继续，对不起。所以你在遛猫？不，我们去散步。
I go for a walk, an hour's walk. I scruffled dogs. Ricky, why don't you and Jane have a dog? Because I know you love dogs. I know... But why are you guys more... Are you consider yourself cat people, or why don't you have a dog?
我去散步，散步一个小时。我揉揉狗。瑞奇，为什么你和简不养只狗？因为我知道你喜欢狗。我懂……但为什么你们更偏向……你们认为自己是爱猫人士，还是为什么不养狗？
No, I absolutely love dogs. I love all animals. I think to me, all animals are unconditionally perfect in beauty. I agree. The only animal that I think you can ethically keep is a pet, a domesticated animal. But I love all animals.
不，我绝对爱狗。我爱所有的动物。对我来说，所有动物在美丽上都是无条件完美的。我同意。我认为你唯一能在道德上当做宠物饲养的动物是驯养动物。但我爱所有的动物。
But the reason I have a dog is we travel too much. And a cat, you can have a cat's here. It doesn't care, OK? Yeah. A dog, I can't stand a dog. The dog doesn't understand. They have an emotional intelligence beyond some people. I can't bear that I have to travel so often with a dog.
但我之所以不养狗，是因为我们旅行太多了。而猫，你可以养一只猫放在这。它不在乎，好吧？对。狗，我受不了狗。狗不懂。它们的智慧有着超越某些人的情感。我无法忍受经常带着狗去旅行。
So wait, then what happens with the cat? The cat just stays home. You leave out a big, big bowl of milk and... No, we have people look after it, don't we? You fall. Like the Flintstones. Yeah. So your guess is that cats are so emotionally stable and secure
等等，那猫怎么办？猫就呆在家。你留下一大碗一大碗的牛奶然后……不，我们有人照顾它，对吧？你倒。就像《摩登原始人》里那样。对。所以你的意思是猫的情绪非常稳定和安全，
that you can go travel around doing all your shows for a couple of weeks and they're good. But a dog, your guess is that they're just emotional basket cases and they need you there a little bit more often than once every couple of weeks. Well, it's based on knowledge. Science. Because of all the interviews they've done
所以你可以出去到处巡演几周，它们也过得很好？但对于狗，你的意思是它们只是情绪脆弱的温室花朵，它们需要你更经常地陪伴，而不是每几周才见一次？好吧，这是基于知识。科学。因为他们对猫和狗做过所有的采访。
with the cats and the dogs. Yeah. So is Jane a dog or a cat? Jane's a woman. Oh. No, I'm kidding. Is she like the independent, like you can go away and I don't need to see her?
对。所以简是狗型还是猫型？简是个女人。哦。不，我开玩笑的。她是那种独立的，就像你离开她也不需要见她的那种？
Or is she a dog where she's like, I'm going to miss you. I need you back. Oh, I see. Oh, I see. I was trying to elevate. Jane's got some sexy indifference, like a cat, right? It's like she doesn't really need you. She's all fine by herself, you know, right?
还是她属于狗型，会觉得：我会想你的。我需要你回来？哦，我明白了。哦，我明白了。我本想升华一下的。简有一种性感的冷漠，就像一只猫，对吧？就像她其实并不那么需要你。她一个人也挺好的，你知道的，对吧？
No. Jane, Jane, Jane. She needs you. I'd like to think Jane needs me. Wait, wait, wait. Can you get through that one more time without laughing? That would be great. Well, we're still rolling.
不。简，简，简。她需要你。我宁愿认为简需要我。等等，等等，等等。你能不笑场再把这句话说一遍吗？那就太好了。好吧，我们还在拍摄。
She needs you and then don't. She does need you and you could bring the dog, you know, because you're only gone a couple of night here and night there because you've got to go and do these arenas. And God bless you. And I feel the same way. I need to do arenas too, but so let me ask you this. So what do you what do you think?
她需要你，然后又不需要。她的确需要你，你可以把狗带上，你知道的，因为你只是在这里或那里离开几个晚上，因为你得去那些体育馆演出。上帝保佑你。我也一样。我也需要去体育馆演出，所以让我问你这个。那么，你觉得呢？
You've been at home. You've been working on. I know you're working on your body. Three. I'm working on my body now. Yeah. That's why you can't see my house. Oh, he's doing, he's doing leg lifts.
你一直待在家。你一直在做……我知道你在锻炼身体。三。我现在正在锻炼身体。对。这就是为什么你看不到我的房子。哦，他在做，他在桌子底下做抬腿运动。
He's doing leg lifts under the table. But you're, you've written series three of life. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I did that quite quickly. Yeah. And series three is season three. Season three.
他在桌子底下做抬腿运动。但你，你已经写好了《后半生》第三季。对。对。我的意思是，我写得挺快的。对。第三季就是第三季。第三季。
Yeah. Sorry, we're European. And that's ready before sort of workshopping and, you know, and all that. And I've basically cast it in my head and that's ready to go. We're filming in April. So I feel like I feel the gap. I can't do gigs at the moment again.
对。抱歉，我们是欧洲人。而且那个在做工作坊排练之类的之前就已经准备好了，你知道的。我基本上在脑海里选好了演员，随时可以开拍。我们在四月份开拍。所以我觉得我填补了空白。我目前还是没法做现场演出。
That's ready to go. In fact, all my gigs this year have been postponed until next year. So I do that after I film. So that's ready to go. What about the jokes in that that might be topical that are not going to work next year? Are you just going to update that? Well, luckily, when you're still doing stuff about, you know,
那个已经准备好了。事实上，我今年的所有演出都推迟到明年了。所以我拍完后再做那些。所以那个随时可以开拍。这里面的笑话如果有时效性，到明年不管用了怎么办？你打算直接更新吗？好吧，幸运的是，当你一直在创作关于，你知道的，
Hitler and famine, AIDS, it's pretty fucking timeless. Evergreens. Yeah. Yeah. Good for you. We're always, we're, luckily we're, we're always up killer diseases and fascism. Yeah.
希特勒、饥荒、艾滋病这些话题时，这些内容基本上他妈的是永不过时的。常青树。对。对。真为你高兴。我们总是，幸运的是，我们总是围绕着致命疾病和法西斯主义。对。
So, How do you think that looks so you're ready to go back on the road. You've been working on your stand up sort of nonstop and refining it. I will have to change it slightly. I will have to, I think, depending on what happens, because I think if the vaccine comes in, I think people don't want to forget it. And so it wouldn't be, it wouldn't be timeless. And if I was doing it now, I'd start with it.
所以，你觉得这看起来怎么样？你准备好重新上路了。你一直在马不停蹄地创作单口喜剧并不断打磨。我必须稍微改变一下。我想，这取决于将来的情况，因为我觉得如果疫苗问世，人们不会想去遗忘它。所以它就不会是永不过时的。如果我现在在表演，我会以这个开场。
In fact, I did a couple of little warm-ups when we were doing social distance gigs and I started off with going, it's great to be gigging. I haven't gigged this year. The last normal time was Christmas, wasn't it? That was the last time with friends and family. And we didn't have, we didn't have a traditional Christmas. You've got to move with the time.
事实上，在实行社交距离的演出期间，我做了几个小型热身演出，我的开场白是：很高兴能演出。我今年还没演过出。上一次过正常生活还是圣诞节，对吧？那是最后一次和亲朋好友在一起。我们没有过，我们没有过一个传统的圣诞节。你得与时俱进。
We might be cultural. We had bats. We had a load of bats. Oh, you, you ate bats. So I started off and got it. Oh, shit. We should talk. Ricky, who, who makes you laugh?
我们可能很文明。我们吃了蝙蝠。我们吃了一堆蝙蝠。哦，你，你吃了蝙蝠。所以我一开场就说这个。哦，操。我们该聊聊了。瑞奇，谁，谁能让你笑？
I know you get asked this a lot. It is like one of those standard questions, but fuck it. Who makes you laugh? Well, you do. You know that. Well done. Well, present company excluded, present company. We got what we wanted.
我知道总有人问你这个问题。这就像是那些标准问题之一，但管他呢。谁能让你笑？好吧，你啊。你知道的。干得好。好吧，在座各位除外，在座各位。我们得到了想要的。
Oh, you have to, you have to categorize it. You have to categorize. I mean, I mean, I, are there people who the way that they, Larry David, I think, I think Larry David is underrated. I know he did the biggest sitcom of our generation, but I think Curb Enthusiasm, 10 series of Curb Enthusiasm and the quality just hasn't changed. And he's remarkable and he's brave and he's funny and he's a great
哦，你得，你得把他们归类。你得分类。我的意思是，我的意思是，有没有人，他们的那种方式——拉里·大卫，我觉得，我觉得拉里·大卫被低估了。我知道他拍了我们这代人最成功的情景喜剧，但我认为《抑制热情》，十季的《抑制热情》质量一直没变。他很了不起，他很勇敢，他很搞笑，而且是个伟大的
performer. He's fearless. You guys are very similar that way. Self-effacing too. Yeah. I think, I think he's the, all around comedic creator of the past 25 years. And Chris Guest, it sounds like Chris Guest, you like a lot too,
表演者。他无所畏惧。你们俩在这方面非常相似。也很谦逊。对。我认为，我认为他是过去25年来全能的喜剧创作者。还有克里斯·盖斯特，听起来克里斯·盖斯特，你也很喜欢，
yeah. Chris Guest, probably the biggest single influence on me is both the sort of, his style, a friend and a mentor. Cause I knew no one in the industry. And when the office went out, Chris Guest called me, he said, his wife had seen it and said, you've got to watch this. And he loved it. And I could see why he must have seen his influence in it.
对吧？克里斯·盖斯特，可能对我影响最大的单个人物，无论是他的那种风格，还是作为朋友和导师。因为我在业内谁也不认识。当《办公室》播出时，克里斯·盖斯特打电话给我，他说他妻子看过后对他说：“你必须看看这个。”他很喜欢。我能看出他肯定在里面看到了他自己的影响。
But he called me up and just said, I don't want to say it. And I was blown away, of course. And then we became friends. And then I'd call him when I wanted advice. I remember an early film, I did, they wanted to do one of those screenings where 40 people give you notes. And I said, I don't want to do it. And he said, why would you?
但他打电话给我只是说：我不想多说什么。我当然震惊极了。然后我们成了朋友。接着当我想征求意见时，我就会给他打电话。我记得我拍早期电影时，他们想搞那种有40个人给你提意见的试映。我说我不想去。他说：“你为什么要听他们的？”
He said, if you're letting them edit it next time, why don't you write it with them? And I just thought that was such a lovely, wow. And then he told me a story that the director of Rain Man did one of those things. And his favorite comment was, I enjoyed the film, but I was disappointed that the little guy didn't snap out of it by the end.
他说：“如果你下次还要让他们剪辑，为什么不干脆跟他们一起写算了？”我当时觉得这话太棒了，哇。然后他给我讲了一个故事，说《雨人》的导演就经历过那种事。他最喜欢的评价是：“我很喜欢这部电影，但我很失望那个小个子到最后也没能恢复正常。”
And so he'd given me that, those little nuggets. To fear Mal TV by committee. And he's just lovely and he's still funny. I remember he asked me once, he said, we'd just be mucking around like, you know, idiots, like kids. And he said, if we're suddenly not funny and no one finds us funny, how will we know? And I said, who cares?
所以他给了我那些，那些小金条。要对委员会式的制片室电视保持警惕。他就是很可爱，而且依然很搞笑。我记得他有一次问我，他说：我们只是像白痴、像小孩子一样在胡闹。他说：“如果我们突然不好笑了，没有人觉得我们好笑了，我们怎么会知道？”我说：“谁在乎呢？”
Who cares? We're laughing. We're sure. That Ricky, I have a semi serious question here. I don't want you to cry when you answer it, but with all of the information we've heard about how you started and what you thought you were going to be and the music and whatnot, you're in your mid fifties.
谁在乎？我们在笑。我们……瑞奇，我有一个半严肃的问题。回答时可别哭哦。结合我们听到的关于你是怎么起步的、你以为你会成为什么样的人、音乐以及其他种种信息，你现在五十多岁了。
Have you exceeded your expectations? I'm fucking out. Of course I'm fucking out. Well, but I mean, I'm assuming there is a higher place. We always sort of reset our goals as we start to approach them, right? Yeah. Where are you at right now?
你觉得你已经超越自己的预期了吗？我他妈的当然超越了。我当然他妈的超越了。好吧，但我的意思是，我假设还有一个更高的高度。当我们开始接近目标时，我们总是会重新设定目标，对吧？对。你现在处于什么状态？
Are you satisfied and yet still want more? Or have you hit, ah, I'm past where I ever wanted to be and I could get happy with retirement even and know that I've done it. Yeah. Before you answer that, Ricky, just know how great it is to hear how Bateman's brain works. Go ahead. I think you hone it and hone it.
你是感到满足却又渴望更多？还是说你已经达到了“啊，我已经超越了曾经所有梦想的高度，即使退休我也能感到幸福，因为我已经做到了”的境界？对。在你回答之前，瑞奇，先想想听贝特曼的大脑是如何运转的是多么棒的一件事。请说。我觉得你不断地打磨它，再打磨它。
You keep folding the samurai. You keep honing it and what you like and what I like. And what I like is no interference and only doing things I absolutely love. So I want to do less and less and just more of the thing that I absolutely love. And that that's come down to, I suppose, if I'm doing sitcom, it's just doing the, you know, what with no compromise here and standup
你不断地折叠这把武士刀。你不断地打磨它，打磨你喜欢的东西和我喜欢的东西。而我喜欢的是没有干涉，只做我绝对热爱的事情。所以我想要越来越少地工作，只做更多我绝对热爱的事情。而这归结到一点，我想，如果我在拍情景喜剧，那就是做那种，你知道的，在这里没有任何妥协的作品，而单口喜剧
is already there. Really. There's already no standard compromise for standup. I think standup is like just about the purest art form outside the novel where what you think is what you can say and it's what they hear. And that that's pure because even with someone like after life, you know, I get final edit, I do it all, but there's still 60 people
已经达到那种境界了。真的。单口喜剧已经没有什么标准的妥协了。我认为单口喜剧就像是除了小说之外最纯粹的艺术形式，你脑子想的什么就能说什么，而观众听到的就是什么。这很纯粹，因为即使对于像《后半生》这样的人来说，你知道的，我有最终剪辑权，一切都由我来做，但仍然有60个人
involved. You still have to go there to give it to someone and they still have to go, we put out on this day. You said, whereas standup, I say, I want to do this for you on this day, sell the tickets, the tickets. I go up, I'm doing this. This is it. Good night.
参与其中。你仍然得把作品交给某人，他们仍然会说“我们在这一天发布”。你明白的，而单口喜剧则是，我说：“我打算在这一天为你做这个演出，卖票吧，票卖出去了。我上台，我就演这个。就这样。晚安。”
And every single step of the way is absolutely as I want to do. So it's more and more, how do I get to that? And I've always known that the most important thing is being sort of happy really. I've always tried to cut out the middle man. Just wanted to be, I'll show you a story that sums it up. I think we must have been like 1971. I was like 10 in school and there was a big, there was a big thing in
而且整个过程中的每一步都完全按照我想做的方式来。所以越来越多的是，我如何才能做到这一点？我一直都知道，最重要的事情其实就是保持快乐。我一直试图砍掉中间商。只想成为——我给你讲个能总结这一切的故事。我想那一定是在1971年左右。我大概10岁，在上学，当时发生了一件大事，
2007 is where a lot of unskilled or semi-skilled workers were getting money to go on oil rigs. So you had carpenter, they were suddenly going to oil rigs and where they were earning like 50 quid a week, they were earning like, you know, 500 quid a day on these oil rigs. It was a big thing. It was a big thing in the paper. And I remember the teacher doing a thing to the class saying, okay kids,
2007年是许多非技术或半技术工人拿钱去石油钻井平台工作的时候。所以你会有木匠，他们突然去石油钻井平台工作，以前他们一周只能挣50英镑，但在这些钻井平台上他们一天能挣，你知道的，500英镑。这是一件大事。报纸上登得沸沸扬扬。我记得老师在班里搞了一个活动，说：“好了孩子们，
what would you do with the money if you could earn 500 pounds a day? And it went round and the kids were saying, I'd buy my mama house. I'd buy a car. I'd buy a horse. And it came to me and I said, I'd work one day a week. And I remember, I was thinking, that would be amazing because I could have the other six days. I'm with you, man.
如果你一天能挣500英镑，你会用这些钱做什么？”大家轮流回答，孩子们说：“我要给我妈妈买栋房子。我要买辆车。我要买匹马。”轮到我时，我说：“我会一周工作一天。”我记得，我当时想，那太棒了，因为我可以拥有其他六天。我懂你，兄弟。
I really admire, first of all, you know, I'm a huge fan of your stand up. And I think it's so, I watch it in awe because I think it's so scary to, you know, it just seems like the scariest, it's like you say it is so right. It's just you and your relationship with the audience and everything that's coming out. And man. But it's not, it's not scary.
我真的很佩服，首先，你知道的，我是你单口喜剧的超级粉丝。我觉得这太……我怀着敬畏的心情观看，因为我觉得这太吓人了，你知道的，它看起来就像是最吓人的事，就像你说的，确实如此。这只是你与观众的关系，以及所有迸发出来的东西。天哪。但它不是，它不吓人。
It's the thing that you do it. I think driving a car, Gary, because I can't do it. But when you realize that you've got that safety net for the first, you go out there and you try stuff out. And if it's not working, you don't put the tickets on sale. I've done 50 gigs before I set out a real gig. And I know what it's going to be like. It's going to be the same as the, you know, I mean, the scary thing is,
这就是你所做的事。我觉得开车载人，加里，因为我不会开车。但当你意识到你有了那种安全网，最开始时，你走上台去试段子。如果不管用，你就别把票拿去卖。我在办真正的演出之前已经做了50场小型演出。我知道它会是什么样。它会和……你知道的，我的意思是，吓人的事情是，
you know, recently the scary thing is, you know, this cancel thing being canceled. If you say the wrong thing and suddenly, you know, Netflix can take you off their platform or, you know, so that that's the scary thing. But how do you vet that then? How do you really go through your stuff and who's going to be the arbiter? Well, you can't, you can't because you don't know you could be the most woke politically correct stand up in the world at the moment, but you don't
你知道的，最近吓人的事情是，你知道的，这种取消文化。如果你说错了话，突然间，你知道的，Netflix会把你从他们的平台上撤下，你知道的，所以那才是吓人的事情。那你要怎么审查这些内容呢？你要怎么仔细检查你的材料，谁来当仲裁者？好吧，你不能，你不能，因为你不知道，你可能是当今世界上最清醒、政治最正确的单口喜剧演员，但你不知道
know what it's going to be like in 10 years time. You can get canceled for things you said 10 years ago because you don't know what's going to be like in 10 years time. And it also seems like the people that try to use specifically, because I remember that the golden globes where all of them, they're so fucking funny, but you were so great. But I remember the same people it seems that try to cancel you are also that your fans are also the people that hire you and also the people that
仍然想跟你合作的人。关于这个，我觉得，关于取消文化的误解在于，你知道的，有些人认为你应该能够说任何你想说的话而不用承担后果。这不是真的，因为我们是社会成员，人们有权批评你。他们有权不买你的东西。他们有权烧掉你的DVD，他们有权关掉电视。
still want to work with you. The thing is about this, I think the, the miss of the standing about counterculture is, you know, some people think that you should be able to say anything you want without consequences. And that's not true because we're members of society and people are allowed to criticize you. They're allowed to not buy your things. They're allowed to burn your DVDs and they're allowed to turn the telly off.
他们无权做的是霸凌其他人，不让别人去看你的演出。或者有些人，有些医生是极好的医生。他们因为在推特上开了一个糟糕的玩笑而被医院解雇了。我会想，嗯，那与他们的工作无关。所以我认为，我认为这并不是被取消。这叫没有平台发声了，对吧？
What they're not allowed to do is to bully other people into not going to see you. Or there's some people that are, that are, that are doctors are great doctors. They're getting fired from a hospital because of a bad joke they made on Twitter. And I'll go, well, that, that's not relevant to what they do. So I don't think, I don't think what's being canceled. It's having no platform, isn't it?
他们能把我怎么样？因为我已经有了，我已经有这个了。谁能取消我？推特？YouTube？如果必须的话，我可以去海德公园站在长椅上大喊大叫。所以我惹上过很多大麻烦。他们差点取消我，因为，因为我杀了一个流浪汉，我
And what can they do to me? Because I've got, I've got this now. Who's going to cancel me? Twitter? YouTube? If I have to, I go to Hyde Park and stand up on a bench and shout shit. So I got in a lot of shit. They almost cancel me because, because I've, I killed a hobo and I
心想这跟我的工作毫无关系。不。那是我在周末干的事。好吧，这也是另一回事。你，如果你没有违法，人们最多也就是不买你的东西。而有些人被取消是因为他们，他们真的触犯了法律。
thought that's nothing to do with my job. No. That's something that I did on a weekend. Well, that's the other thing as well. You, if you don't break the law, people just cannot or not buy your material. Whereas some people get canceled because they've, they've actually broken the law.
我把这作为我关于“究竟什么是被取消”的新段子来讲。我想那才是真正吓人的地方，因为那是真正的后果。对。没有人再去关注论点本身。他们只看是谁说的，然后就做出决定。这里面没有任何细微差别。而且其中一部分归咎于政治，一部分归咎于社交
I talk about this as my new standard about, you know, what, what is being canceled. And I suppose that's a scary thing because it's a real consequence. Right. No one looks at the argument anymore. They look at who's saying it and they make their decision. There's no nuance. And if some of it's down to politics, some of it's down to social
媒体，因为速度太快了。速度实在太快了。正如我所说，20年如果你对电视上的某个人感到被冒犯，你会拿出一支笔和一张纸，写道：“亲爱的BBC……”哦，操，我才懒得写呢。现在你随手发一条推特，这条推特就会登上该死的新闻，因为别人跟你吵起来了。所以这就是这种路怒症。
media, because it's too fast. It's way too fast. As I say, 20 years ago, if you were offended by someone on television, you got our pen and paper and you went, dear BBC. Oh fuck, I can't be bothered. Now you fire off a tweet and that tweet goes on the fucking news because someone else argued with it. So it's, it's this road rage.
事情发生得太快，以至于你无法收回，人们固执己见，人们渴望被听到。人们希望觉得自己产生了影响。这就是为什么人们会嘘一个喜剧演员。他们想觉得自己当时在场。“我当时就在现场。”所以现在人们都被听到了。而且麦克风的音量都是一样的。
It's things happening too fast that you can't take back and people dig in and people want to be heard. People want to feel that they had an effect. It's why people heck look a median. They want to feel they were there. I was here. And so now people are heard. And the microphone is the same volume.
每个人都能使用它。是的。一个白痴在推特上站在天才旁边，看起来一模一样。字体完全一样，没错。而这正是最危险的地方。天才赢得了这一切，而白痴没有。然而人们根本不再做这种区分了。好吧，完全正确。
Everybody has access to it. Yes. An idiot stands next to a genius on Twitter and it looks the same. It's the same font and exactly. And that's what's so dangerous. And the genius has earned it and the idiot hasn't. And yet people don't, they don't make that distinction at all anymore. Well, exactly.
这就回到了我们一开始所说的话，仅仅因为你感到被冒犯，并不意味着你是对的。近年来，我们遇到了这样一种现象：人们会说，“我的价值和其他人的价值一样高。”这没问题。但最近我们变成了“我的意见和你的事实一样有价值。”而这就不对了。
And it comes back to what we said at the beginning just because you're offended. It doesn't mean you're right. In recent years, we've had this thing where people would say, my opinion is worth as much as the next person's. And that's true. But recently we had my opinion is worth as much as your fact. And that's not true.
现在人们对事实感到被冒犯。人们现在知道，当我表演“生日快乐，46亿岁了”这个段子时，我是在调侃原教旨主义者。他们知道，他们会想：为什么他们……因为他们把事实当成了个人攻击。人们把事实当成个人攻击。我可以跟你连续聊九个小时这种事。我太喜欢了。
Now people are offended by facts. People now know that when I do happy birthday, 4.6 billion years old, I'm having a go at fundamentalists. And they know they go, why are they? Because they take facts personally. People take facts personally. I could talk to you about all that stuff for like nine hours straight. I love that.
我喜欢所有的内容。哦，天哪。我敢打赌他正期待着呢。我是说连续聊。没有打断。没有睡觉。瑞奇，你刚才说的是哪个笑话？你提到人们感到被冒犯或者在网上、
I loved everything. Oh man. I bet he's looking forward to that. And I mean straight. No interruptions. No sleep. Ricky, what was that joke that you talked about? You said that sort of that idea of people being offended or online or
在社交媒体上，就相当于跑到城镇广场上……哦，当人们，对，我在《人性》里演过这个，有个女人跟我争论，被一条推特冒犯了。就像，我是在发推特。就像，我只是在发推特。我根本不知道谁在关注我。这就好比你走进一个城镇广场，看到一条留言写着：“吉他课。”
on social media was the equivalent of running down to the town square. Oh, when people, yeah, I do it in humanity when there's that woman's arguing with me, getting offended by a tweet. Like, I was tweeting them. Like, I'm just tweeting. I don't know who's following me. That's like going into a town square and seeing a message says, guitar lessons.
然后你走过去说：“我他妈才不想要什么吉他课呢！”然后说，人们，又不是针对你的。人们挡在子弹前说：“你为什么对我大喊大叫？”我太喜欢这个了。而且人们是故意这么做的。他们试图给出人权的观念。这就是原因。所以如果你批评基督教，人们会说：“你为什么要批评……”
And you go, I don't fucking want guitar lessons. And say, people, it wasn't to you. People jumping the way of a bullet and saying, why are you shouting at me? I love that. And people have done that on purpose. They've tried to give ideas of human rights. That's why. So if you criticize Christianity, people say, why are you criticizing
然后你会说，我他妈才不想要吉他课。然后说，各位，这又不是对你说的。有人挡在子弹前面却说，你为什么要冲我喊？我喜欢这样。而且有人是故意这么做的。他们试图提出人权的概念。这就是原因。所以如果你批评基督教，人们会问，你为什么要批评
Christians? And I go, I'm not. I'm criticizing the idea. I'm, you know, I'm discussing an idea. It's like me getting offended where someone hates maths. And it's not mine. Maths isn't mine. It's a concept.
基督徒？然后我说，我不是。我在批评这个观点。你知道的，我在讨论一个观点。这就好比有人讨厌数学，而我因此被冒犯了一样。数学又不是我的。数学不是我的，它是一个概念。
It's an idea. So, but anyway, this is for our nine hour podcast. Man, that's going to be a real hit. I tell you what, part two through 12. When are you coming to Los Angeles or when? Will always gets to see you, always gets to hang out. I want to, and I won't bring Sean. I see.
它是一个想法。所以，不管怎样，这是为了我们九小时的播客准备的。天哪，那一定会大受欢迎。我跟你说，第二到第十二部分。你什么时候来洛杉矶，或者什么时候？威尔总是能见到你，总是能一起玩。我想去，而且我不会带肖恩。我懂。
I do. I do actually see four people when I'm in LA. Don't I? I can be small. How about four and a half? Will and Mitch. I don't like you, but you're always having a body wax or something. Yeah.
我是说真的。我在洛杉矶时其实会见四个人。对吧？我的圈子可以很小。四个半怎么样？威尔和米奇。我虽然不太喜欢你，但你总是在做身体脱毛之类的。是的。
Hurry out here, please. Or I'll come see you there. Don't make it like you don't know me when I call you. You'll never come to England. I want to come. What did you call it? Leafy? Where do you live?
快点来这里吧，求你了。不然我去看你。别当我给你打电话时装作不认识我。你永远不会去英格兰的。我想去。你刚才叫它什么？多叶的？你住在哪里？
Will's been here. Will calls me up and goes, I'm around the corner. I go, what? He calls me up. Is it all the time back and forth between Samarits and... Yeah. He's hopping off yachts and shit. I never go to Samarits.
威尔来过这里。威尔给我打电话说，我在附近。我说，什么？他给我打电话。是经常在萨马里茨（Samarits）之间来回吗……是的。他从游艇上跳下来什么的。我从不去萨马里茨。
I only get stars. So, listen, I didn't even say it right. No, you didn't. Well, listen, yeah, I do miss hanging out and I do miss going over there. I love spending time in the UK and I love spending time with you. All right. Goodbye. We love you.
我只跟大明星在一起。所以，听着，我甚至没说对。不，你没有。好吧，听着，是的，我很怀念一起玩，也很怀念去那边。我喜欢在英国度过的时光，也喜欢和你在一起的时光。好了。再见。我们爱你。
Goodbye, Ricky. We love you. Ricky, thank you so much, man. Guys, and remember, well, you tell the other guys, if anyone asks, is he in the SAS? No. He's just a comedian. Right. Okay.
再见，瑞奇。我们爱你。瑞奇，太谢谢你了，伙计。各位，记住，呃，你告诉其他人，如果有人问，他是SAS（特种空勤团）成员吗？不是。他只是个喜剧演员。对。好吧。
Got it. Got it. Okay. Play us off real quick with something with that. Grab that guitar. Grab something. Just a quick little... Just a single chord.
明白了。明白了。好吧。用那个给我们弹奏一曲，快。拿那把吉他。随便拿个什么。就一小段……就一个简单的和弦。
Oh, we didn't have to twist this, huh? Here we go. Here we go. Pretty girl on the hood of the Cadillac, yeah, she's broken down on freeway nine. I take a look and get her engine started, leave her purring and a roll on by, bye-bye. Free love on the free love freeway. Love is free. Freeway is long.
哦，我们不用费劲扭转这个，对吧？我们走吧。我们走吧。凯迪拉克引擎盖上的漂亮女孩，是的，她在九号公路上抛锚了。我去看一眼并帮她发动引擎，让她发出咕噜声然后开车驶过，拜拜。自由恋爱在自由恋爱高速公路上。爱是免费的。高速公路很长。
I got some hot love hot love highway going home because my baby's gone. She's gone. Ricky Gervais, everybody. Wow. That was awesome. Incredible, Ricky Gervais. Thank you, Ricky. You're beautiful, mate.
我有炽热的爱，炽热的爱公路，正要回家，因为我的宝贝走了。她走了。瑞奇·热维斯，大家。哇。太棒了。难以置信的瑞奇·热维斯。谢谢你，瑞奇。你真美，伙计。
Ricky, you're gorgeous. Hey, listen, it's getting late. You're going to have to get those, those prop awards back to the prop house. Okay, buddy. Wow, look at that. IPA dead. Love you, Ricky. Bye, pal.
瑞奇，你太棒了。嘿，听着，天色不早了。你得把那些道具奖品送回道具仓库了。好吧，老兄。哇，看那个。IPA没了。爱你，瑞奇。再见，朋友。
Bye, buddy. Bye, bye, bye. Bye, bye, bye. Thank you. It's great fun. Oh, what a man. How great was that? Well, I love that you guys knew him.
再见，伙计。拜拜，拜拜。拜拜，拜拜。谢谢。太好玩了。哦，真是个好人。这太棒了吧？嗯，我很高兴你们认识他。
I've never met him. I'm such a... Yeah, no, and I was serious about the influence he had over me, over the show, over, I just, I think he's it. Have you guys ever seen him debate religion with Stephen Colbert? No, I would... I mean, I've seen him debate religion with lots of people. He does it online.
我从未见过他。我真是个……是的，不，我是说真的，关于他对我的影响，对节目的影响，我只是觉得他就是那个人。你们看过他和史蒂芬·科尔伯特辩论宗教吗？没有，我……我是说，我见过他和很多人辩论宗教。他在网上这样做。
He does it in person. Yeah, it's really interesting. Wait, does Colbert... Colbert is Catholic. Yeah. And, and Ricky's saying... He's an atheist, yeah. Really?
他当面这样做。是的，这真的很有趣。等等，科尔伯特……科尔伯特是天主教徒。是的。而且，瑞奇说……他是个无神论者，对。真的吗？
Yeah, it's really fascinating. He's incredible. Anyway, I'm a huge fan of his. I think he is, has a brilliant mind. He's an incredible guy. He's so, so funny and he's such a sweet, which is funny because like Jason, you were saying, you know, some of his characters, he can be very confident. Even though he can be self-evasing, he can also be very confident, but he, and he is confident.
是的，真的很迷人。他太不可思议了。总之，我是他的超级粉丝。我认为他拥有出色的头脑。他是一个不可思议的人。他非常非常有趣，而且非常温柔，这很有趣，因为就像杰森你说的，你知道，他的某些角色，他可以非常自信。尽管他有时会自嘲，但他也可以非常自信，而且他确实很自信。
He's just a smart guy. He's a very level-headed and sweet, sweet guy and super smart, which is why it was good to have him on our show because he was able to help us. Yeah, I love that thing at the beginning where he's like, wow, are you guys just idiots? Yeah. It's called smart lies. Yeah, we go ahead and give you a big hint, right? The bar is low and it's advertised.
他只是个聪明人。他是一个非常冷静、温柔的人，而且超级聪明，这就是为什么能邀请他上我们的节目很好，因为他能帮助我们。是的，我喜欢一开始他说的那种话，哇，你们这群白痴是吗？是的。这叫聪明地撒谎。是的，我们提前给你一个大提示，对吧？标准很低，而且是公开的。
I want to meet Jane. I want to hang out. I have met Jane, but I want to hang out with her. I'm fascinated to see what... We'll include you guys. I'll include you in the dinner. Yes, please. I would love that.
我想见简。我想跟她一起玩。我见过简，但我还想跟她一起玩。我很着迷，想看看……我们会带上你们的。晚餐会带上你们的。好的，拜托。我太想去了。
Yeah. The one thing he didn't say, though, as he was signing off was... Bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的。不过他在最后告别时唯一没说的一句话是……再见。这集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。